chris cuomo may be out at cnn but he
wants 125 million dollars and he's
backstabbing the network now accusing
cnn of malfeasance and unethical
journalism which i find kind of funny
because the things he's calling them out
for we mostly know about and he could
have called them out when he worked
there so it just goes to show what his
real intentions are he's going to hurt
the network for the sake of hurting them
because he wants money but this should
be interesting to talk about because we
also have another story the new york
times now finally admitting once and for
all the hunter biden laptop story was
real and that has serious implications
for joe biden the current president
while we are seeing this war in between
ukraine and russia how we may be
involved in it and now based on new york
times's admission plus we already knew
the laptop was real we have questions
about joe biden's conflicts of interest
with this country
we could be we could be looking at world
war iii and we know this guy has got
illicit business dealings here this is
going to be
it's just bad so we'll talk about that
we've also got the us dumping more out
of our strategic oil reserves we've got
gas being stolen in huge quantities
because the prices are so high and we
have this story russia is funneling cash
to anti-fossil fuel climate extremists
apparently one thing that russia is
trying to influence is stopping the us
from having energy and it makes sense
putin wants to destroy us what do you do
go after their infrastructure divide the
country we'll be getting into all of
that stuff joining us to discuss this is
congressman randy weber would you like
to introduce yourself sir well thank you
i sure will paul you can pull the mic up
i sure will appreciate that that's a
little bit better
great to be here randy weber
congressional district 14 in texas we
are the gulf coast of texas starting
from louisiana and go down those four
counties we've got seven ports more than
any other member of congress
we export about 90 percent of the
nation's lng from our district uh we
have a lottery fighting we produce 60 uh
almost 20 percent of the nation's
gasoline east iraqis lng for people who
aren't familiar liquefied natural gas
you betcha uh 20 of the nation's
gasoline east of the rockies my ports
don't include houston the port of
houston if you jump up 25 miles north i
mean get port of houston it's 80 percent
of the nation's jet fuel wow and 45 of
the nation's gasoline east of the
rockies we are a huge energy exporting
district a lot of hunting fishing
farming tell you what there's more
concealed handgun licenses uh licensees
in my district in texas than any other
member of congress in texas and i'm
assuming in the united states but you
don't need them anymore
that's right they've gone to
constitutional carry
you betcha so we were glad to see that
you know i served in the texas house for
four years before i got demoted in
congress
and and i actually was able to carry on
the floor of the house all four years we
need that privilege we uh we have that
privilege up here in d.c it's just that
the left doesn't get it regular people
in d.c don't have that privilege they're
working class well that's right that's
right they are i mean they're communists
in d.c already and they want to become a
state no thanks yup yup i hear you i
have a concealed handgun license in
washington dc one these are getting them
it's very expensive but wow and you're
in congress and that's right but
citizens should not have to go through
that it's communism i mean
hitler knew it take away the guns first
yep yep all right well we got a lot to
talk about thanks for joining us we also
have lisa reynolds hi guys i'm lisa
reynolds i do communications on the hill
for congressman randy weber oh i gotta
get closer to you i know keep it close i
always do that um
and i do political consulting so here we
are perfect cool and i'm seamus coughlin
i make cartoons i have a youtube channel
called freedom tunes if you guys want to
check that out i just released a cartoon
today sort of
lampooning the fact that we are
constantly using world war ii nostalgia
to try to rope america into foreign
conflict so if you guys want please go
check that out even if you don't want to
check it out anyway leave a comment
telling me how much you hate it i love
the engagement and sheamus yeah do you
know what day it is
it's uh no actually what is is there
something significant is there some kind
of significant irish festivity occurring
irish american festivities that is
correct it is saint patrick's not
wearing green i think patrick is a great
man yeah oh we do yeah good irish
whiskey we sure do i think we do i think
so oh we have scott we have scottish
whiskey no that's not the same we're
close enough that's not close enough
randy's wearing green you're wearing
green yeah yeah yeah
i don't need to you know i very much
don't need to it does not it's um people
get the memo it's true it goes around
news gets around about sheamus it is
saint patrick's day i am the pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow i'm very
excited for tonight's conversation let's
get going ian is not here tonight he is
out sick sheamus will be taking his
place
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a members only segment coming up
around 11 or so p.m and as a member you
are keeping all of our journalists
gainfully employed they're all very
excited to hear that people are signing
up on the regular so we really do
appreciate it and again you'll get
access to those members only segments
you don't want to miss them so don't
forget also smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
right now take that url post it wherever
you can it's the most powerful thing you
can do to help out let's read this first
story and i want to talk about chris
cuomo because
we have a story from timcast.com chris
cuomo accuses don lemon and jake tapper
of violating journalism ethics the
reason why i think this is fun to start
off with because it shows the inner
workings at some of these big media
companies cuomo himself he's ousted from
cnn
he's now accusing other employees at cnn
of wrongdoing but he knew they were
doing this while he was there and he
said nothing i'm sure these other people
who work there know they're all doing
things that are bad and considering what
we see consistently with the media lies
i just thought it would be good to start
off today with just
very very uh you know deep breath deep
breath in
they're admitting they're liars i feel
so it's so good chris cuomo now is
backstabbing the organization i'm glad
to see it i am glad to see it too one
thing i think is hilarious though is
chris cuomo coming forward and saying
the people need to know
cnn isn't reliable
someone has to tell them
if not me how will they know let me read
this real quick chris cuomo is seeking
125 million dollars from cnn for
allegedly wrongfully terminating him and
he is throwing his former colleagues
under the bus in his attempt to get it
in his arbitration demand filed on
wednesday cuomo alleged that jake tapper
don lemon former cnn president jeff
zucker and former executive allison
gallis engaged in blatant breaches of
journalistic ethics quote as long as
zucker and gallus believed cnn's ratings
would benefit they were more than
willing to disregard breaches of
traditional journalistic standards by
cnn personalities such as don lemon and
jake tapper or even to engage in blatant
breaches of journalistic ethics
themselves cuomo's filing stated not
that we all didn't already know this but
it's good to hear it and i just want to
point out one more thing in this
document from uh from the the filing i
was really hoping it was going to be on
march 15th that cuomo uh issued this
statement the eyes of march yeah but it
was march 16th
so basically what he's saying is he
shouldn't be she he shouldn't have been
fired because everybody else was doing
it and that was the culture there and so
now
it's okay
now like now everybody's in trouble well
no now he's saying like look look how
look they they fired me it was wrong you
know look at what a stand-up guy i am
yeah that's right well i i think what
he's basically saying is if they're
firing me for violating these ethics but
they do it every day
that was wrongful termination well
listen uh to be accused of violating
journalistic ethics don't you have to be
a journalist and don't you have to have
ethics i mean that's what i'm saying
right yeah
yeah
yeah also the idea of him accusing
anyone of breaching ethics in media it's
like oh did they not do enough reporting
on the uh the governor of new york did
they did they not talk about him
properly because there's some kind of
conflict of interest there and they look
the other way on it that's crazy it's
not like you tried to help him yeah what
are you thinking right you know i was on
there three ti two or three times and
and we watched this guy remember back
during the pandemic when he was telling
everybody wear a mask and then there's
pictures of him out in public without a
mask i mean it's unbelievable the
hypocrisy it transcends so many parts of
our culture it's unbelievable i mean he
faked being in quarantine he did he
pretended he did in his basement right
yeah working out yeah when he was
actually at one of his properties in the
hampton some kind of fat tire bite rolls
up and it's like hey aren't you supposed
to be quarantined he's like who are you
and he gets in his face yeah yeah you
know i think we have a serious problem
in this country
where
you know we were talking just before the
show downstairs and i i said we have a a
low light filter for the chicken city
you said we need a low life a little
life builder for congress i'll tell you
yeah and i said but that would get rid
of basically everybody maybe a handful
of people that's true and you know i'm
just thinking about
there are so many people who believe cnn
they turn it on or it's in the airport
or it's in uh their hotel rooms they
listen to it and they they think this
stuff is real
and and now you know even now with cuomo
coming out and being like oh yeah they
just blatantly breach ethics for ratings
they're still going to be people who
just believe what they say yeah right
and they blatantly breached ethics for
ratings have that work for them by the
way
all right piling on piling on well no
you're right hold on truth be told their
ratings were they were doing well during
the trump years oh well absolutely
you know it did work out until but even
then i don't think it was the breaching
of ethics that worked for them i think
it was just the constant trashing of
trump and any of trump's supporters too
yeah it didn't matter about facts and
exactly and you can argue that that's
absolutely a breach of ethics but i
don't think they would ever describe it
as that so with him making these
accusations i doubt that's what he's
referring to but i mean according to
chris cuomo we've all we've all breached
ethics by looking at the wikileaks
because it's really easy for us to do
something that was tapper wasn't it no
that was following that
yeah
said that uh it was illegal to look at
the whip wikileaks well my apologies to
jake tapper for falsely accusing
you yeah so uh as as somebody's in
congress though i'm sure you've dealt
with them misrepresenting your positions
tell us tell us
oh lisa that doesn't happen right
i tell you when the reporters come up i
want to stick a mic or a phone in your
face you're going uh no i think i'm fine
i'll tell you what
it is palpable the the fact that they
want to misrepresent things we say all
of the time and you all know that you
see that uh and thank god for your show
because the american public is waking up
to this
and we appreciate y'all bringing it out
it's unbelievable i'll give you one
example of a story i really like is uh
there was a guy who was accused of being
a white nationalist i asked the
journalist i said hey this guy does not
he's in a mixed-race relationship he's
got a mixed-race child and the
journalist goes is he white and i was
like yes and he goes is he a nationalist
and i said yes he was white nationalist
and i was like oh come on
that was that's you know how dirty that
is and that's that's the game they play
oh absolutely they did it to me i'm not
even anybody i was talking in a
clubhouse room once about officer cynic
and saying that he didn't he died from
natural causes and they were like oh
congressional staffer
blames capitol police for officer sit
next death i'm like that's not what i
said i said he died of natural causes
and then i turned out to be right you
know the article's still up there
so what is this we got it times v
sullivan we gotta we gotta
get that looked at by the supreme court
or something or or what to be because
right now they can just lie
they can they can they do these really
clever tricks where they'll say fact
check there's one uh the new york times
ran saying fact check
republicans falsely accuse biden of you
know driving up gas prices and then they
they show some quotes from you know
mccarthy and from mcconnell and from i
think lindsey graham and they're like
they accused joe biden of shutting down
oil and gas leases and saying that drove
up prices but according to the experts
we've decided to talk to these two guys
they say it's wrong therefore it's a
fact check and i'm like that's an
opinion piece absolutely it is and so
this is what they do all the time they
can run opinions claim it's fact they
can outright say it is a fact that this
happened and then when they get sued
they say oh that was an opinion and then
the courts are like okay they want to
hide behind that and like you say that
ought to be tested you betcha and we see
that all the time what do they call them
some call them pinocchios they give it
two three four pinocchio that's
washington post yeah seriously
i mean they ought to have the most
amount of pinocchios right yeah i guess
i guess you know i also question the
washington post's pinocchio system it's
not that pinocchio would clone himself
when he lied his nose would grow longer
so maybe they would be like his nose has
grown five feet longer and said they're
like now there's more of them right yeah
well at least with pinocchio you knew
there were strings attached oh yeah
absolutely
the washington times you've got to read
that with a grain of salt assault
washington post you've got to read that
with a grain of salt washington times is
pretty good actually it is
this is weird though let me ask you
there's a strange thing in that
conservative media has their faults they
get stories wrong but they have a
tendency to be more correct than say the
new york times how is that what what
what is this that you know my background
was not uh as a conservative republican
i grew up in chicago liberal democrat
all that stuff but my my concern is with
what is true and effective what is
working and so when i read the new york
times and i see lie after a lie i just
eventually turned it off i stopped i
stopped look i i stopped going to their
site with cnn i used to have cnn running
on the running
on on in the background 24 7 while i was
working and then one day i realized they
stopped covering news and it was just
panels with their opinions about trump i
started turning it off all of a sudden
now you know i'll google search a story
and you're more likely to find the truth
on a conservative or right-leaning
newspaper than you would at cnn msnbc
the new york times or otherwise why is
it that's even if you can get it to pull
up like if you pull up like i'm saying
talking about office we tried right like
we talked about officer sitnik you have
to go to the second or third google page
to see the autopsy reports and what the
coroner actually
deemed like the fake stories are still
there you can't even try pulling up any
fox news article it doesn't even come up
well there's values in our constitution
you know this freedom of religion
freedom of press you can go right down
that list and i think conservatives
still want to live by that document that
founding document they understand how
important it is
and the left not so much they'll stretch
the truth and quite frankly there's been
a lot of people myself included that say
look you guys are trying what you're
doing is going to destroy the foundation
of this country if we stand by and let
you and we shouldn't stand by and let
you i tell people when they ask me what
when they find out i'm a conference and
they say what party what are you
republican or democrat and i tell them
i'm a christian conservative republican
and in that order we've got a foundation
for this country the founders were
brilliant in what they set up and the
left wants to get away from it and
that's part of the problem
why why why do you so we talk about this
a whole lot but i'd be interested in
your perspective on why the the the left
in this country is more than just the
left you've got the establishment
democrat voices as well as the
progressive voices why why do you think
it is they want to get rid of the
constitution and those founding values
if you've got the people depending on
you you can keep getting reelected
it's pretty simple really when you think
about it it doesn't matter what party
you're in they want government to be the
answer well i'm from texas you know
we're very proud to be from texas we
were a country of our own right we get
it in texas and we don't want big
brother big government doing anything
for us don't help us please
think about it the first time we're
guaranteed the right to
life liberty in the pursuit of happiness
not guaranteed equal happiness and what
you're seeing now is a government that
wants to say look we'll take care of you
we'll give you equal happiness it
doesn't matter what the constitutional
into the declaration of independence
says we're going to take care of you and
they will keep getting reelected i think
there's a couple things too like
absolute power corrupts absolutely but
on top of that they don't want to
confront their own morality so when they
start saying like
you know i when
when their values don't or the bad
things they do don't align with society
they want to make excuses for it and and
that's why our republic is falling too
because it was meant for a virtuous
society and we are losing virtue we have
a saying for that
rules for thee
but not for me that's what you're seeing
well let's talk about how serious it
gets we have this uh this story here
from the national review the new york
times suddenly discovers hunter biden
laptop and corruption investigations are
real this is this is amazing yeah hunter
biden is being investigated for crimes
and uh the reporting is uh that he he
paid off he took a loan out i guess to
pay off his tax burden hoping they
wouldn't indict him but apparently the
feds don't care because they're like if
you falsify your taxes you're in trouble
paying it off later doesn't change
anything or how about illegally
registered get a handgun rather
you know what's funny about that is the
double standard so frozen family hunter
biden what did he do he he lied on his
uh
absolutely yeah he lied on it saying he
wasn't doing he didn't do drugs
drugs right and a lot of them yeah but
it's on video everywhere yeah here's the
challenge right the first challenge is
the double standard we all agree that's
a problem you don't get to come out and
say we got to follow these rules and
then the president's kid gets to break
all the rules
the second thing is however i don't
think i think it's it's burdensome to
get a firearm in the first place and so
maybe there's an argument about a simple
background check that doesn't even take
that long but if you have a right to
keep and bear arms then we got to talk
about what the constitution means and
what the limits are so i'm always wary
to to you know come out and be like oh
he had a gun the wrong way and i'm like
well you know
if he was doing drugs that i get now
you're a criminal and you're due process
you through due process you do lose
certain rights that's right that's true
but i also want to make sure we keep the
door open to say like
i'm i'm a big fan of nationwide
constitutional carry so there there was
a bumper sticker came out in the in
texas i don't know about up here back
probably in the 60s or 70s and it said
when guns are outlawed only outlaws will
have guns
it's just that simple the criminals and
the thugs and ronald reagan said it he
said the best way to get gun control is
to lock up the criminals and thugs that
have been convicted of a gun crime put
him in behind the jail and then throw if
you don't throw away the key at least
lose it for a long time
well here we go we now have the new york
times
openly admitting
that let me read a little bit here they
say if you are really industrious you
can dig 20 pages into the a section of
today's new york times and find a 1 700
word news story by three of its top
reporters relating that the justice
department's investigation of president
biden's son hunter is not merely a tax
matter turns out that prosecutors are
probing his penchant for cashing in on
his father's political influence through
payments by overseas entities for which
he did not register as a foreign agent
well even better if you weighed 23
paragraphs into the story you will learn
that prosecutors are examining emails
between biden and his business
associates that come from a cachet of
files that appear that appears to have
come from a laptop abandoned by mr
hunter biden in a delaware repair shop
you don't say
this is the story that the new york uh
the new york times had said was you know
russian disinformation cnn uh uh maybe
not the new york times because i want to
misquote them but i know several
reporters were saying it was just
information it was questionable byzan
himself said it was russian just
different
jen sackey said it was russian distance
according to these intel sources
politico it was natasha bertrand she was
with politico and now cnn put out this
story which was a fabrication because uh
i love this glenn greenwald's reporting
he said even in the story where she said
intel sources say it was disinfo the
intel sources said we are not saying
it's disinformation we're saying we
don't trust the information so this lie
comes out now the big issue is the media
lies to us
not every single entity i mean the new
york post they published this they were
getting us that information big tech
colludes with the media and now because
of this there's a few interesting polls
media research center and rasmussen
found i believe it was rasmussen that if
regular people if you're voting if
american voters were aware of this story
around six to i think 17 percent would
not have voted for biden they doesn't
mean they're voting for trump but that
would have had a big impact on the
election absolutely yeah now think about
the war in ukraine
with russia invading and ukraine saying
we want these big fighter jets we want
nato support and who's the president a
guy with corrupt business dealings
through his son in this very country and
that has me worried these are the
ramifications of media lying to us yeah
absolutely so 45 percent of biden voters
said they did not know about hunter
biden's deals and 9.5 said as you
mentioned they would not have voted for
him had they known and now the new york
times is coming out and saying hey
remember that thing we called you crazy
conspiracy theorists for believing well
put a dollar in the jar because a couple
months later you're allowed to believe
that thing
yeah and that's exactly what we saw all
the time we in our district i'm very
conservative district we you know i took
ron paul's place in congress
oh yeah very conservative district on
the gulf coast and and we give you
excuse to fill yeah i was going to say
that is a tough spot to be in big shoes
quite an honor well thank you you betcha
and i had this endorsement when i ran
along with governor rick perry and then
attorney general
greg abbott and ted cruz and i can go
right down the list because they know
how conservative i am
but we put all that information out in
our district making that point and our
the jefferson county in our district was
the only swing county out of 254
counties in texas we're turning them red
they were democrat a lot of salt to the
earth people fishermen welders
electricians a lot of refineries and
stuff on the coast
and the jefferson county voted for obama
in 08 re-election in 12 and in 2016 they
went for trump wow so they got it down
in our district we wish we could
duplicate that replicate that you know
across the country you bet they knew
that but they purposely put it out
they
wanted to suppress the story right
before the election that's when it came
out like yeah that's when it hit it was
project veritas that dropped it no no
it's near post it was an aircraft in new
york new york who dropped the story i
mean who put out the story though that
it was that we found hunter biden's
livestock new york post it was i'm
pretty sure the new york post was the
first to publish the story yeah that's
why they got taken off twitter yeah and
they got you you couldn't even share i
remember this you couldn't message a
friend the link that's true twitter was
blocking it i remember that talk about
evil people
authoritarians
oligarchs whatever you want to call it
so my question is you know over the past
several months i've just been saying at
a certain point with all the lies you
know justice millet now free men believe
how how about that we get more we get
stories every single year some big news
cycles some big protests and it turns
out to be a lie or manipulation and i'm
just thinking how do we just finally say
to the likes of cnn and the new york
times or whatever you guys can go play
over there with your dwindling audiences
and we're going to keep the truth here
and have these conversations somewhere
else how do we how do we create our own
narratives right well one thing one way
was what you said earlier hey look tell
your friends about this show right you
know that's why share share share you
know you better hear that everybody the
congressman says share the show
share share you bet well right now we're
chasing our tales though republican
messaging in general is still having to
respond to the national media the
mainstream media and instead of putting
our own content out we are here we are
again responding to fake news stories
over and over again rather than
highlighting what we should be doing and
what's wrong i want to that's what the
narrative is and what should what should
we be focusing on yeah sure you guys
familiar with the defiant l's huh you
ever see defiantly on twitter and
instagram
it's great uh define else takes uh two
tweets and uh places them together for
comedic effect the first tweet we have
here is from jen saki who says hunter
biden's story is russian disinfo dozens
of former intel officials say they
didn't that wasn't true and then below
it is the new york post hunter biden's
infamous laptop confirmed in new york
times report yep
it's a scary prospect oh you can't make
this stuff up well i mean they can yeah
that's all they do
yeah the scary thing i suppose is we
laugh
at being right and we laugh at the
absurdity but look at gas prices look at
inflation look at the afghanistan
withdrawal look at what's going on in
eastern europe the this these lies and
this manipulation is burning our country
to the ground now the thing is the left
the antifa
when they get tricked they scream until
their vocal cords shred and they smash
windows and start fires right we point
out the lies and start laughing and
saying ha ha we were right the whole
time there's there's this vile rage that
is being wielded through the
manipulation the media that does give
them power
and it's causing problems and harm to
this country well that's all the
attention is aimed toward them and then
they say you know what can we these poor
people they need
they don't need more police they need
social uh social workers yeah and i'm
like oh my gosh you can't make this up
what did reagan say lock up the the
thugs and the criminals and throw away
the key yeah a little much for me i'm a
bit libertarian in in you know in a lot
of these rega respects but i think the
issue is we're seeing uh the other side
of that extreme extremism from the
progressives in places like new york
where they let all the criminals out oh
sure and then you get there was one guy
who was a like a 40 time repeat offender
who was laughing being like y'all locked
me up the first time just let me go and
it's like he's going to keep doing it so
there's a real challenge i think the big
challenge is with big cities though i i
really am not a big fan of cities i grew
up in cities lived in them until only
the past few years i think you know i
come out here to the middle of nowhere
everything's much more relaxed it just
absolutely you're more likely to know
who your local uh deputies are sure you
go and meet him you talk to him you
elect your law enforcement you go to
these big cities and it's just faceless
law enforcement faceless judges nobody
talks to their neighbor and that leads
to the kind of authoritarianism it leads
to the police brutality the left is
complaining about all the time yeah well
let me brag on texas for a minute
because where i'm from we know all of
our elected officials and i live in a a
district of course we're about uh not
quite 900 000 people now with the
redistricting
and in my county one of the biggest
cities is league city it's about 110 000
and then beaumont's about a hundred
thousand and so there's big cities
around right and we know all of our
elected officials in texas we're so pro
uh law enforcement pro-life and and
pro-gun you can go right down the list
we know and they know us too and they
know they can depend on us and we can
depend on them probably not so much in
the northeast chicago west the left
coast as i call it some
yeah this is so i think one thing that's
really important in the in the
discussion about police is that new york
is very very different from you know
beaumont for instance absolutely so
people in new york when they're saying
defund the police or whatever they're
talking about a bunch of different
problems my response to a lot of these
uh you know blue city uh urban police
departments is they were locking down
people for covid violating their
constitutional rights shutting down
churches so i'm like by all means get
rid of them why well these are democrat
voters and democrat cities who voted in
democrats who appointed these cops the
cops shut down churches now they want to
get rid of them i'm like get rid of them
do you think i say let it happen look at
what's happening in seattle right now
let them let them destroy themselves
you see all these like murder rates
going up and crime and now serial killer
in new york but even in amazon's moving
their their one of their main
headquarters out of seattle because of
all the violence that's been happening
with on the street and so the people
that are that are in that city have to
look around and say this is what we get
for saying defund the police this is
what we get for these little let them
destroy themselves you know in texas i
wasn't there this time because i was in
congress but they passed a bill this
last time for about sanctuary cities and
said look if you're a sanctuary city in
texas and you don't believe in enforcing
immigration law and all those things
you don't get any state funding
you want to defund your police and be a
sanctuary city and you want state
funding nope if you're a sanctuary city
you get zero funding austin was one of
the ones who cut the police i think i
was going to say they just pointed the
figure at austin right you know the
people's republic of austin
and and i think they defunded it's like
100 or 110 million i forget the exact
amount and so greg abbott and company
got in gear and they said that's fine
you want to defund the police well we'll
just you get no more state money and by
golly do you know that one very short
order i don't know a month or two later
that austin came back and put 110
million whatever dollars was back in the
budget for the police this this all this
kind of stuff you know freaks me out
because you've got people from
california moving to austin moving to
texas
and what they don't understand i had a
we had a ton of people telling us you
guys should move to austin and we're
like we're gonna go to west virginia or
at least the west virginia area for the
most part and the thing about texas is
when when joe rogan for instance you
know he's a good dude when he moves to
austin
it's because he thinks california is
going crazy and you can you can
reasonably talk to him and say you're
not going to support those kind of
policies are you and he'll tell you you
know he's like oh i i wouldn't i
wouldn't do that i'm not going to move
to an area
but support staff
what happens when elon musk you know he
moves to texas right he's going to bring
his factory those employees are going to
move with them these are california
residents they're going to vote blue and
he's going to bring them all into texas
and he's going to start
bringing in democrats into texas so that
that freaks me out
it's concern for us too and of course
you know it's free country across state
lines but what we want to do is make
sure the californians have to apply for
a passport right and a visa to come
visit texas and we laugh about it but it
really is true and there's talk about in
from the texas delegation up here that
there's been reported signs in
california that says the last one out of
california turn off the lights wow so
the amount of people coming to texas
1300
people a day right not all not all from
california yeah dfw every three minutes
gets a new resident
every three minutes every three minutes
florida and texas i think are seeing the
largest population increases right now i
i will say and maybe i'm being a little
naive here but i just want to try to
throw some optimism in there are a lot
of conservative people in california who
just don't vote in any of their
elections because they see their state
as hopelessly blue and i hope that those
are the kinds of people moving off to
texas and so you're going to have an
influx of red voters as well but
obviously the blue voters coming in and
trying to change the face of the
political scene there is a huge problem
yeah it is shameless and we're not
unaware of that there's actually a group
that's out there registering voters
correct we go back and we look at
california i know the ones you talk
about that don't vote you know they're
not going to be on record
but we're going back and you know you
can't find out how somebody voted but
you can find out if they voted and if
they voted in republican primary they
identify as republican democrat
libertarian green or whatever
or independent and the group is busy
working right now identifying those
republican voters and when they come to
texas they're sending them the letter in
the mail with a are you registering to
vote you know here's your chance you'll
register to vote that's amazing good for
you guys are you familiar with scott
pressler
know the name how do i know that he's
probably the most famous voter
registration activists right now
yeah there's memes about them because
it's uh you know you'll see a tweet from
someone where they're like i'm just sick
of the city i moved to texas and then he
responds right away have you registered
to vote at your current address so
there's a meme where it's like a dog
answers the phone and the dog's like
hello and he's like hey this is god
pressler have you registered to vote
because yeah but uh he's doing he's done
amazing work in um i think his work has
led to what like the republican party in
florida becoming bigger than the
democratic party something like that
yeah we're saying we're saying the
border crisis too turned some border
towns that were traditionally blue
really red too so that's that's
absolutely mcallen texas elected a
republican mayor yeah yeah isn't it
hilarious how as soon as left-wing
people actually have to face the
consequences of their policies instead
of getting to shove it off onto somebody
else they mysteriously turn red or they
leave yeah
think about it in this context because
we talked about getting the news out how
the news meted twisted everything and
that's why i think it's important people
listen to this right you know did i
mention people ought to share this did i
mention that yes yes absolutely and you
are so correct leave a comment too yeah
i didn't know if i mentioned that super
chat us but so they're not getting real
news down there but when they see
illegals coming across the border now
when i was in the state house i was on
the borders of committee my second term
i was the vice chair
and back then there were in that one
year there were it was 2010 11 rather
there was 5 000 texans who were either
hurt raped violently attacked
burglarized murdered killed
by people who shouldn't even be in texas
and let me do some math for you if we've
got 70 000 kids coming across the border
a month and we've had that if you think
about kindergarten education k through
12. i was on the public education
committee for four years k through 12.
do this math if you've got 70 000 kids
coming across the border let's just say
the average school k through 12 is 10
000.
that is seven complete school districts
that you have to fund
right somebody's got to fund now i get
that they don't all land and stay in
texas
you know we the federal government is
their logistics group the drug lords
bring them up here human trafficking and
and we latch on to ngos and under the
biden administration and they move them
inland but somebody's going to pay to
educate those kids and that's per month
when we have those kinds of months seven
complete school districts per month yeah
so okay oh yeah i mean for years the
democrats have argued that it's
misinformation to say that illegal
immigrants receive any kind of welfare
or state funding and firstly there
actually are illegal immigrants who have
family members who are on welfare and so
they receive it that way but also when
you enter into a country and you're not
registered in the system and paying
taxes but you're receiving benefits from
the system it's functionally the exact
same problem one one of the uh
most interesting points that i was
reading about when it comes to illegal
immigration is how they affect
the uh presidential vote because the way
we vote is by electoral college right
and so when you get non-citizens in a
district they still count towards the uh
census right yep so that means the uh a
state with a large population of
non-citizens will get
an extra district or two based on those
non-citizens which means an extra
electoral college vote that's right
texas got two texas got two this year
and by the way two extra seats because
of non-citizens well well
population growth well we had both i
mean it's hard to say how many our our
great border patrol and our great texas
dps and we've got a lot of folks down on
the border we love our law enforcement
down there when i was in the texas house
my first term we put 200 million dollars
on the border
and that was for helicopters and boats
and ships gun boats literally we've got
five boats on the on rio ground river
with machine guns louie gomer and i've
been down there and actually toured that
area
now they're putting three billion
dollars a session because they only meet
every other year two sessions two years
on the border and the federal
government's not doing their job yeah
they and so yeah we're growing we don't
know we don't know how many people we've
lost they will give you they will give
you the number that they handled and
then they'll give you an ex a an
estimate on the getaways that they don't
know how many got away have you have you
talked to
some of these people down in these
border districts as to what's going on
like what what are people thinking and
feeling as to why they're switching from
democrats absolutely i've been on the
border probably five or six times been
in there a number of times remember the
freedom call because we've been down
there i went down there really twice
when i was in the texas legislature and
then i've been there four five six times
i've been in congress and they're sick
and tired if you talk to the ranchers
and the farmers and the business owners
down there and the city officials
they're tired of biden's policy they're
tired of just letting them cross come
across it's unbelievable
i've heard some crazy stories oh listen
and you know this is sickening but uh
the drug lords down there they they will
make those young girls they'll take them
and they will be violated raped if you
will they will be violated numerous
times coming up across the border there
and they actually have trees where they
hang the the clothing of their victims
we're talking
women's underwear and stuff like that in
trees and they call them trees they call
them and i've been there and seen
with my own eyes it's a it's appalling
and i don't get why the bible
administration the democrats don't see
that you know they need to stay in their
own country if they want to claim asylum
then let they can stay then go to the
embassy in that country when when you
give people accurate information it's
interesting how
the democrat narrative makes no sense so
for instance you go to a regular
american and say should the united
states help people who are fleeing gang
violence and need asylum they'll
probably say yes
you'll say
follow up
if these people are coming from say
brazil
should they be allowed to trek all the
way up through all of these countries
and through mexico into the united
states for asylum most people will say
wait what no
once they've escaped the danger they're
safe where they are they can stay there
right that's right so what's happening
now is we're hearing stories about
people traveling from ethiopia from
africa over over overseas absolutely to
brazil and you know what really offends
me about this they land in brazil and
then they trek all the way up to the
united states brazil is awesome right i
i i was chilling on copacaban on the
beach with the coconut and i'm like what
about brazil do you not i don't i don't
understand but i i get it america is
it's the benefits benefits
we're we're a wealthier nation than
brazil and so they're safe in this
country
but they're willing to risk the lives of
their children and themselves because
america is just that much better well
you ask a regular person should we grant
them asylum they're going to say no
absolutely
well tim when i was there the director
of the dps there
my youngest son is a special agent for
the fbi and
steve mccraw was a former fbi guy
retired and rick perry appointed him and
we found out i had fbi family we had a
great relationship
and he told me that there's 40
different eastern religious sects
s-e-c-t-s
40 different this 2009
40 different eastern religious sects
coming across our southern porous border
we don't know who's here
we don't know who's here that ought to
scare people big time islamic extremists
are also making plans to come up from
from the horn of africa and they're
coming in i think it was like joseph
whom i or somebody that had been
tracking that for a really long time
i've actually heard from several
journalists that uh extremist groups
know they can enter through the southern
border rather easily and that's one of
the main ways to get in yeah absolutely
one of the points you were making is
about how as soon as you have more
information the democratic narrative
falls apart and that's a huge part of
the reason why they have to call people
names for disagreeing with them and why
they have to frame every issue really
dishonestly so if you look at the
conversation that we're having on border
security very plainly it's essentially
one group of people saying
there should be some vetting of people
at the border we should have a handle on
who's in here people should become
citizens because we
as a democratic nation
supposedly where the people have a say
should have some say on who's entering
the country the other side of the
discussion is literally just
there should literally be zero oversight
on who is entering the country the
people should have absolutely no say
when you put it that way it's extremely
obvious which side of the issue you
should be on whether you consider
yourself liberal or conservative but the
way they frame it is well either you
think everyone should be able to come
here and get whatever benefits they want
or you're racist yeah and we're look if
we don't have a border we're not a
sovereign country and people accuse me
all the time randy and and by the way i
have a website randywebber.org so if
anybody wants to see what i believe it's
easy to find me randyweber.org
but uh i tell people all the time they
say well you just you just hate uh max
you know mexicans people south of the
border and hispanics and that kind of
stuff and i said no i said you don't
like immigration you just want to con
close the whole border down i said no
my grandfather and my grandmother came
over on the boat from germany
i am the grandson of german immigrants i
wouldn't even be here but they guess
what they did it legally and that's what
we're saying come in to build the
country don't come in to take from the
country and that's the difference well
and not only that it isn't simply an
argument on the ethics of why a person
should want to come here it's simply a
statement that we should have some
handle on who's coming here we should
know who's in our country it's
constitutional congress makes
immigration and naturalization laws not
the president of the united states but
we really need to think about why they
don't care why they think it should be
that way they they want these people to
come in because they want them again
dependent on them so that they they'll
get their votes and and they can
maintain more power and implement
their
progressive ideologies i think we should
uh allow every single person in the on
the planet
to immigrate to the united states
but it's got to be through a controlled
legal process which means there's also
going to be certain times at which we
can't allow people to come in what i
mean to say is everyone should have the
opportunity to try absolutely but this
means if we can't handle the burden it
means if we we can figure out where
people can go to i went to sweden to
explore the uh refugee crisis and a lot
of the claims that were being made about
it a lot of people on the right were
saying that violent crime was through
the roof because of these refugees that
were coming from the war in the middle
east
as it turns out while that was partly
true there was an increase in crime for
that reason a lot of the crime we were
seeing was due to the uh somali refugees
of the 80s and 90s and their children
growing up feeling stateless feeling
like they weren't part of the community
why what happened was when those people
came in in the 90s
sweden didn't track where they were
going what they were doing and so they
formed enclaves they went they were they
were told by sweden okay everybody move
here and then you're good so then they
had kids those kids grow up in an area
where everyone speaks the same language
but they're but they're they're swedish
citiz they're swedish citizens but
people in sweden who are white you know
natives did not view them as swedish
they viewed them as immigrants then they
would go home to their home country to
see their parents and they would be
called swedish so all of a sudden you
have these individuals who feel
stateless because they weren't able to
integrate they weren't given the
opportunity the reason why you have
checkpoints and borders and an
immigration process is to maximize the
opportunity for those who are actually
coming to the country if you look at
what the left is defending with these
poorest borders it's children
wandering through 90 miles of open
desert being found dead in ditches
being being left without parents being
left sick one of the most disgusting
things i saw
there was a young child i think it was a
little girl maybe like 11 years old who
died and the news reports were like
child dies in ice custody and it's all
this all this crazy and then the story
actually was the ice
found a sick girl dying in the desert
and did everything in their power to try
and save her life and so they rushed to
the facility and she died and the media
tried framing it like they killed her i
remember that yep i've been there with
my own eyes and seeing the facilities
that they have and let me back up and
just say this too that look if we're
going to let
if congress is going to increase them
immigration quotas by country that we
have
that's up to congress that's
constitutional but we're going to have
to have the facilities and the
infrastructure to do that we're going to
have to have immigration courts
immigration judges immigration officers
then we have to have facilities and so
it's going to cost the american taxpayer
more dollars so here's the question
shouldn't we when somebody comes to
america wants to immigrate and come
across the border should we charge them
fifty dollars a hundred dollars five
hundred dollars should they help pay for
the infrastructure absolutely absolutely
uscis already processes though a million
um petitions a year we let in about 500
000 immigrants from all over the place
every year and people don't realize that
we have we take in the most amount of
immigrants
out of any other nation in the entire
world
our immigration system while it it has
its issues is still
letting in so many people think about
that you're letting in 500 000 people
legally a year on on green card
petitions and they process a million
applications yeah to your point about
how much should people pay when they
come in some of these stories you you we
hear about families spending three
thousand dollars or more or more and so
it's fascinating to me that the
narrative from the left is often oh
these poor refugees who are so broke and
helpless and i'm like they got three
grand paid drug cartels yeah it's not
trafficked up here and it's dangerous
you know they don't got 50 bucks to help
us afford the cost to make sure that i
mean we're talking about helping people
who are genuine asylums or whatever get
get proper placement that means we need
infrastructure we got to pay for it it
does cost money to immigrate here
through like uscis but we they have feed
petition waivers that you can you can
fill out and you can come here for free
you can you know fill out all the
paperwork and file it with uscis if you
file a feed petition waiver and claim
some hardship so it's actually less
expensive to do it the right way yeah
than it is to to come over and be
smuggled by drug cartels unless you're
trying to break through the border and
sneak into the country
i want to i want to pull up this story
real quick because you guys had
mentioned this before the show and it's
an interesting story axios is reporting
biden officials fear mass migration
event if coveted policies end axios
reports u.s intelligence officials are
privately bracing for a massive influx
of more than 170 000 migrants in the
mexico border if covet-era policies that
allow instant expulsions during the
public health emergency are ended
sources with direct knowledge of the
discussions tel axios the response
underway includes a newly created and
previously unreported southwest border
coordination center essentially a war
room to coordinate an intra-agent
interagency response
so they're basically saying the title 42
has been used more than one million
times to rapidly expel migrants at the
southern border without hearing asylum
claims but the trump era order wasn't
set up to be permanent and senior biden
officials are preparing for its end as
the virus is brought under control
this means that when title 42 ends
all of a sudden 170 000 migrates are
going to rush the border
because they can't be instantly expelled
and that means our immigration system
won't be able to handle a massive influx
of that an influx of that magnitude
they're already not able to handle it
we've had for the last every month since
biden has been elected
has the people crossing the border has
increased in january from from january
to february it just went up another
seven percent but our media has totally
forgotten about the border crisis in
general they don't talk about it anymore
our cbp is already overrun so they're
they're saying they're going to they
they need to uh beef it up we're already
under prepared what should we do well
just remember my school example 170 000
people if one-third if it's mom and dad
and one child what's the third of 170 is
that like 55 60 not quite sixty thousand
that's right sixteen
six more school districts in one event
and when you talk about asylum people
have to remember that when you when you
request asylum asylum from what
religious persecution
fear of your government there's actually
categories for it it can't just be
my neighborhood's bad there's no money
and all that kind of stuff and the drug
cartels are bad i get that they live in
bad neighborhoods and your heart goes
out to them i get that
but they come here uneducated they come
here to take jobs right that americans
from americans in many instances and so
they have to ought to go to the united
states embassy whether it's bolivia
whether it's argentina whether it's
mexico guatemala and apply for asylum
there
and the best thing biden could have done
was to let trump's policies stay in to
effect on energy
on
on immigration and a whole lot of things
if biden has just done nothing from
first day but he starts reversing them
all and we're seeing the effect of it
you see there's there was a video
one of the migrant caravans several
years ago they were coming from i think
honduras they're in they're in mexico at
the southern uh they're in southern
mexico
and they get the announcement that
mexico will offer them all asylum and
refugee status in mexico and someone in
the caravan yells how many of you
want to stay in mexico and then he says
how many of you want to go to america
and they're like yeah
yeah so they were they were given asylum
it's crazy to me because i think the
issue is
for
people on the left
i gotta tell you man they think mexico
is a desert they think mexico is all
sepia toned
they watched movies and it's just like
it's on narcos they're like this is the
entire pokemon like every every movie
about mexico they just set your tone and
then i'm like have you ever been to
mexico city it is a city it is a big
city they have buffalo wild wings it's
awesome
vox had ran a quote from one of the
migrants in the caravan several years
ago and they somewhat a journalist from
a french journalist asked this migrant
why do you want to go to america and he
said i miss buffalo wild wings and i'm
like well hold on there a minute i
absolutely relate to that b-dubs is
awesome but they have b-dubs in mexico i
went to mexico city and specifically
sought out a buffalo wild wings and i
got me some honey barbecue wings with
ranch dressing and it was great it's
funny you say that about mexico because
everybody thinks texans ride horses
every day
which the greenies would probably be
okay with if we rode over here on horses
but i keep reminding them that horses
have emissions
that's the truth yeah big stinky ones
yeah well tim you made a point earlier
about believing that basically everyone
should have the opportunity to enter
this country and part of what's sad
about the current debate
what's that yeah no exactly exactly um
and part of the issue is there is a lot
of opportunity for people or there would
be more opportunity for people to be
able to enter through the legal channels
if our system was not clogged up with
people who are jumping in line to try to
enter the country and i cannot think of
anything more suicidally stupid for a
nation to do maybe a few things but not
many things more suicidally stupid for a
nation to do than say instead of taking
the people who want to follow our laws
and respect our culture let's just bring
in everybody who's willing to violate
our norms and break our laws and not
respect our nation and tell the people
who want to respect it that they can't
come because we brought in too many of
the people in the former category or
they have to be and they are already way
down in the line it takes years and
years and so now you've got an
immigration system that as i pointed out
earlier judges and courts and clerks and
all those kinds of things now that
people are trying to do it legally are
pushed way back because of those jumping
ahead our our asylum court so once they
come here they get released and they're
supposed to go to asylum courts they're
backed up for about four years so they
get let into the country and then for
four years they're allowed to do
whatever they want work wherever they
want
do whatever they need to do before they
even get a hearing to see if they should
be deported around you look at some of
the news reports have been coming out
for the past year so it's much much
worse than that we're hearing uh there
was the video footage released from uh i
think it was westchester new york where
the binding administration has been
smuggling undocumented children illegal
immigrant kids into various states and
you actually had a federal contractor
tell a local cop if the american people
knew what we were doing and he says what
do you mean
the government has betrayed them wow
these are these are we had tennessee
found out because of secret video that
these these uh illegal immigrant kids
were being flown in the middle of the
night into these other states and then
just released
it is it is not just that our courts are
backed up it's that
i view this as the biden administration
is desperately trying to sweep under the
rug what's happening you had those
videos coming out from macallan texas of
the kids under the under the highway
remember that absolutely about 15 000
but it was the biggest biden group that
he ever assembled
you know oh yeah the largest crowd ever
drew no you're not wrong they didn't buy
them
yeah well so i think what they're doing
is we don't want the media to see this
so just take the kids in the middle of
the night and fly them to a random
location you know tim what you're
describing almost sounds like a swamp
oh yeah
amazing that there's bureaucrats in
there that they want to do it their way
and there's so much corrupt and so much
stuff as you point as that guy pointed
out what you just
related their government our government
has betrayed us
in a lot of ways i i think
it's sad to say maybe it's not so much
that our government has but that our
government has been
for the law for a very long time there
are people in our government who don't
care about us don't care about the
country and i think it's apparent when
you see what's happening with schools
how they're teaching that america is bad
or evil they really just don't like this
place and there's that joke about man
all of those freedom-loving cubans who
want to escape and make it or
venezuelans we'd love for them to come
cherishing the ideas of freedom and
liberty and those who want socialism and
communism and hate america can go to the
countries that also hate america it's
like you know we got a disproportionate
uh we gotta gotta have like a prisoner
swap or a population swap right that's
the joke
yeah i mean one can only dream though
it's not a joke
you know here's what i'll say i've said
it before i have infinitely more respect
for the honduran who says i'm going to
travel you know thousands of miles
through desert risking my life because
america is awesome as opposed to these
leftists in the united states who are
like america is evil and wrong and
colonial that being said
jumping the line over someone who has
the same belief and says america is
awesome i'm going to do it right
i would prefer the people waiting in
line believing in america absolutely the
ones allowed in well you know that they
believe in the rule of law they're going
to come they're going to do their dead
best to be a a
a good citizen it's just that simple
yeah just that simple yeah and for the
most part this isn't the case 100 of the
time and i am speaking anecdotally but
when i meet legal immigrants they tend
to be very patriotic people who lean
conservative and they really do not like
illegal immigration they don't and
sheamus i speak a lot of people don't
know this but i speak i mean i speak
spanish so when i'm down on the border
we talk about a
request for asylum you know when you
talk to those families down there many
of them through tears especially the
ladies it breaks your heart the mama's
got a little baby or maybe a
three-year-old five-year-old someone has
three kids with them when you speak to
them you say you know why are you here
what are you doing blah blah they're not
talking about asylum i'm afraid for you
don't think of me i don't i have fear
they're saying
i need a job
and that's their claim
and so you see that every single day on
the border you know what's really crazy
to me is that
several hundred years ago
people from uh all over the world mostly
europeans you know they decided to get
on boats because they needed jobs and
they risked their lives on you know
sailing for three months i think like
what 20 percent of people on these ships
from europe to north america would die
of dysentery yeah like that scurvy or
whatever gross thing and uh uh what
happened when they made it here there
was nothing
you they made their jobs absolutely so
they would just they you know don't get
me wrong a lot of the early settlers
nearly died and that's why we have
thanksgiving cold winters cold winter is
bad man when uh when game of thrones
says winter is coming people people in
the united states don't really
understand what that means anymore
because we have strawberries in the
winter due to technology yeah but it you
know when we're talking about you know
we've got chickens we had a garden for a
while and we're thinking about how much
food are we producing for ourselves more
as a hobby how many eggs how many
berries how many tomatoes and then fall
hits and we're like zero nothing the
berries are no longer being produced the
gardens are all just basically done and
dead the chicken production drops
dramatically we have some chickens that
lay throughout and i thought to myself
like man if we did not have supermarkets
with imported avocados from mexico and
we were reliant on ourselves for food
what would we do well you gotta flow
wild wings yeah yeah absolutely yeah you
drive through you you climb mountains
and you may get there you probably hunt
you know you hunt and prepare but most
importantly you'd store up food
throughout the summer to prepare for the
winter you know that's a great point i i
want our kids to be learning this stuff
they're not getting it in school and
virginia woke up didn't they kicked out
a bunch of state legislators because of
the way they treated school parents and
you all saw by the way parenthetically
in new jersey uh back in this last
november they we unelected the top
democrat in new jersey uh in the senate
uh truck driver beat him spent less than
what was it i don't know hundred dollars
or less than a thousand i don't know six
or eight hundred dollars i don't know if
y'all saw that story a trucker beating
him and that was kind of good news and
bad news the good news is yes we knocked
out the top democrat in new jersey the
bad news is darn we lost another trucker
we got we got a trucker but back to the
kids
they're not learning this stuff and i
went in to get my oil changed here a
while back and i talked this kid was was
very you know impersonable that kind of
stuff personable and so i said it was
thanksgiving i said what's thanksgiving
bob he said well that's thanksgiving um
he's about 21 or 2 years old he goes
thanksgiving you know that's when we
give thanks i said well sure i get that
right that's i got that but do you know
where the holiday where it came from
um i said who are we giving thanks to
for example if we're given things who
are giving thanks to he said
um
was is it the indians
and i said oh my gosh bob let me sit
down let me talk to you for just a
minute and then i relate to him the
story of people coming over here and the
fact that the indians did help you know
help them learn how to farm and raise
stuff like like we know but our kids are
not being taught the history of our kind
of our country
and so so it's fascinating you know my
point was so many people say i need work
and i wonder
you know what can you do to just go and
try and survive
i guess the reality is
you know we we were talking about this
in the members
segment the other day and it was you
know i think it was fairly brutal and
probably offensive to a lot of people we
talk about what schools are doing to
people's children in terms of
indoctrination
and i would often say to parents and to
people you need to stand up for what you
believe in if you're at a company and
they're saying these things and people
would always say like oh i can't risk
losing my job because you know i have
kids and i thought to myself
would how much you know how much would
you be willing to sacrifice your kid to
this indoctrination this dogma for the
sake of comfort so when you see people
come to you at the border and say i need
i need a job
it's because a job in america means air
conditioning it means a refrigerator it
means a it's clean running water
and the reality of the world is that
you would be digging a hole and making a
fire and hunting a deer and having to
find ways to survive from the ground up
but because the united states is wealthy
people are coming here and what they're
saying is please let me share in your
wealth i totally get it this country is
awesome but there's a finite amount of
wealth we don't have infinite resources
so i wonder if what we really need to
start doing for ourselves and for
everybody is
help teach people how to farm how to
develop how to how to you know
farming i think is one of the most
important things if people are having
issues can we help them be
self-sufficient through education
instead of just saying come here and
bask in the wealth are you talking about
giving money to other nations to teach
them how to be self-sufficient teach
them how to farmer do you want them to
learn it and do it here well
that's tough i would probably say
setting up programs with our oversight
in their countries to set up farming
programs and not have people come here
well we have a lot of ngos and
for sure that do that right and they
teach them how to you know have a clean
water and electricity
oh yeah i have friends who did stuff
like that with africa yeah and it's you
know giving them uh information on
farming practices and crop rotation
how to set up wells and everything does
infinitely more
you give a man a fish you feed him for a
day you teach a man to fish you feed him
for the rest of his life when you talk
about we don't have infinite resources
and you're exactly right i remember and
this is what the left is doing they just
want more and more people bigger
government met the government depending
on them and keep voting them in office
there was a scottish professor i think
the university of edinburgh in 17
something who literally his name was
alexander teitler who literally said
back then that democracy can only exist
until the rank and file people discover
they can vote themselves funds from the
general treasury that's right and when
they do
it's over and we're getting dangerously
close that's right oh i think we're
passing let me let me pull up this story
we got from timcast.com
almost 400 gallons of gas stolen from
north carolina gas station this is but
one specific moment but it's part of a
series of stories that i've been seeing
throughout the past week or so where
people are showing up and stealing gas
one of the craziest was that a van pulls
up to a gas pump and they have the
intake
on the ground and the vent had a trap
door pulls up to the pump while they're
pumping gas they open the trap door and
hook into the gas station's reservoir
to steal gas
because gas prices are so high now
there's a meme
i think you know whether whether you
find it in good or bad taste it's a c
it's from when kyle rettenhaus was
crying in court
but now it's him at a gas station crying
holding up a gas pump
crying about the price of gas and you
know why i like the meme because it's
people who don't like kyle rettenhaus
making fun of joe biden and what's
happening with gas in this country and
all that stuff so i i highlight this
story just to show
the the uh level of strain that we're
currently experiencing for a variety of
reasons when it comes to energy and i
want to give a reminder to everybody
that when these climate change activists
say they want to end fossil fuels that
pain you're feeling at the pump where
you're joking about how you're crying as
you spend a hundred dollars to fill your
car up it's going to be 200 300 to fill
your car up when the climate change
activists get their way now i'm not
saying i'm not i'm not passing moral
judgment on climate change activism i'm
saying if you want
fossil fuels to be done with
that's fine but don't complain about you
know 300 bucks to fill up your gas tank
or are you not driving anymore
well look you want
you want you have to have fossil fuels
for our for our military and for that
it's national security
a good energy supply and you all may not
know this but texas is number one wind
energy state in the country we're number
two in solar panels right and we produce
a lot of the nation's fuel oil and gas
and i didn't say this earlier but the
keystone pipeline comes into my district
it moves 830 000 barrels of crude a day
remember when the colonial pipeline
system got hacked into last year i don't
know april or
it was a disaster southeast the
southeastern states that pipeline system
moves a little less than three million
barrels of product a day
so when the colonial pipeline system is
830 000 barrels it's all it's over one
fourth
of the output
of the colonial pipeline system coming
into texas so that we can refine it we
can sell oil gasoline produce jobs
whether it's jet fuel whatever it might
be
the biden people shut that down on day
one
we wouldn't be in such a bad straight
with ukraine if the fossil fuel people
hadn't been doing such a number on i
mean the anti-fossil fuels right they
hate it may just be me but can you can
you power a jet fighter plane with a
solar panel i don't think so well let's
talk about that uh that disaster that
happened when uh texas froze over
absolutely and uh we had we had the
mainstream media saying oh the freeze
did not affect wind energy they're lying
we had people on the right saying well
the wind turbines were struggling to
work in the cold so so can you tell us a
bit about how that how that disaster
happened absolutely you hear the term
ercot electric reliability council of
texas there's nine electric grids in the
united states texas has its own did i
mention in texas things were bigger and
better
but
85 percent of the state is is under
urcot the other 50 which a lot of us in
my district by the way entergy which
does a energy company which does a great
job
so what again growing up 20 mile radius
68 years i've never seen it be 18
degrees on galveston in galveston so
there was a lot of fossil fuel plants
natural gas we have a lot of natural gas
that were shut down normally in the
winter time for maintenance right
because your your our biggest supply for
need for electricity is in the summer
summers in texas are hot you know what i
mean
and so they shut down for maintenance
it was so cold that a lot of those
plants who weren't set up for frozen
pipes because it didn't get that cold
some of their water system froze and
then they couldn't keep pumping even the
ones that weren't down for maintenance
windmills did break
and here's a little bit of the technical
part ercot has to manage the electricity
on the grid it goes by hertz cycles 60
hertz cycles and i don't remember the
exact number but if after all of this
power consumption is being done
if it starts dropping down to 59 point
something or whatever it is
if it gets to a certain degree then
it'll backfeed and it'll burn the
windings in the generators in the
systems that are online wow and so
they've got to shut down neighborhoods
and power grids without warning because
they're watching it in real time they go
okay we're 10 minutes away you can't
email you can't send out letters you
can't knock on doors you can't phone
call people
that's what happened to us uh last year
one of the things that would help with
that would be well let me back up
nuclear power the left hates nuclear
power if we had for no reason for no
reason you want to talk about green you
want to talk about green energy
it's it's it's zero carbon emission
energy it's safe right
it's it's it's remarkable how people
watch hollywood films and now they're
like i don't want clean reliable energy
it's remarkable but tim i saw the
three-eyed cartoon fish on the simpsons
that's right oh yeah
that's a big help right you know and and
the soviets were doing an experiment
which caused an explosion so now none of
us ever can have clean reliable energy
when i was in the texas legislature i
had south texas nuclear project in my
district over matagorda county where i
took my staff in there in 2010 and we
watched them with their own eyes change
out spent fuel rods it was fascinating
they do it cleanly they do it safely
they're back up and running unit one and
unit two and they're recycling the rods
uh well they don't do it like in full
disclosure we don't do as good a job as
france does and but we can learn that
and think about how crazy it is we had
yucca mountain set aside and i've been
to nuclear waste facility in andrews
texas um
and i was waste control especially and
they have a fantastic concrete all the
state of our stuff to put in low-level
radiation waste
and so we've got yucca mountain which
was designed to do that where you could
take it away from almost every town
every city in a facility that was going
to be run by the federal government
where it would be safe and so the libs
didn't want that the democrats didn't
want that they fought against it and so
what do we do
they store that in now they store spent
nuclear waste right on site in all the
neighborhoods oh that's so fast well let
me let me i'll make a few quick points
the importance of nuclear power so one
of the challenges is that it's not
always windy
wind power sometimes can can reduce
production gets reduced often i i will
see wind turbines not even spinning
that's right when it comes to solar at
night i have an issue i'm thinking the
wind the sun goes down at night that's
right it does sure so a lot of these
renewable energies are intermittent in
terms of the generation right so
fossil fuels is reliable but so is
nuclear power
and nuclear power it's fascinating
because zero carbon emissions but for
some reason they reject it it makes me
wonder what you were saying before they
want you dependent upon them so they can
stay in power they always want there to
be a problem only they can fix right
correct if you're watching the
geopolitical thing going back to russia
on youtube right now they've had a a a
a
misinformation program going on against
fossil fuel you know the left has had it
for a long time funneled by running a
russian money
and the the statistics are that russia
has increased their nuclear uh fleet by
30 percent
and germany has cut theirs by eighty
percent and now europe is going to be
dependent on russia and they've planned
that all along and their russian
disinformation program is trying to
knock out our fossil fuels there's a lot
of ngos over here an anti-fracking
anti-pipeline uh anti-shell exploration
that you know uh ngos or you call it
what you want to qualify well 501 3c
i can do this
[Laughter]
and they've gotten money we've it's been
tracked it's been documented i do i do
have that story we'll pull it up in a
second though but uh just just exploring
you know a little bit of energy as it
pertains to texas
the uh i'm confused as to what the
complaint really was from uh from the
left as to what texas did wrong it just
seemed like the only real issue they had
was exploit the crisis and claim it you
know we have the solutions to it when in
reality it seems like a freak accident
let me tell you what i heard right off
the bat i as as again i've got the most
energy probably the most energy dominant
sector now there's production over in
west texas where they drill and they
produce they send it down to pipelines
but we're reports and refineries and we
export a lot of it
people call me and said randy this is
why you know ercot shouldn't be allowed
to control the texas grid it ought to be
the federal government you know
and i said are you kidding me
i said
i said we've got a state agency called
urcot and a lot of them live here and
they
they shop their kids go to school and do
all this stuff here and you want some
washington bureaucrat this was out of
their control we've never had this cold
winter it's never had this is the
perfect storm
and the state agency i mean it was tough
for them and the legislatures when they
met they went in and they did the things
to harden that grid so to speak
you want to give it to some bureaucrat
in washington dc
no thank you yeah absolutely not i'll
remind you that randy is the leading
minority he's the um republican
republican ranking member on energy
subcommittee for science space and
technology so when the republicans win
in november you're going to be there
i'll be the chairman of the energy
subcommittee i just want to throw
i want to throw this in there i'm glad
you brought russia up because i find it
really hilarious how all of the
people who are against nuclear power and
want to demonize it are also really
comfortable with the idea of going to
war with a nation that is armed with
nukes
so we're talking about what's going to
be more likely to result in nuclear
annihilation it's frustrating oh just
give me the answer straight you know if
someone so here here's what i'm saying
before if someone comes to me and they
say you know i don't like fossil fuels
carbon emissions are bad i'll say okay
but gas is going to be extremely
expensive for the average person the
average person won't be able to commute
then they start saying oh that's not
true and they just lie they lie i had
somebody on facebook saying you know i
have no problem paying five dollars a
gallon for gas because i have a clean
conscience and ukraine is the suffering
and then i talk about how biden is
causing this and they just lie no he's
not biden actually has no no ability to
change the prices and unlike he ended
these oil and gas leases over climate
change lawsuits he's shut down keystone
which is is going to affect supply and
demand he's absolutely had an impact on
these things strategic oil reserves he
has a lot of power to change these
things he's absolutely responsible not
for literally everything but as our
leader and his actions yes but people
lie they lie that's what i can't say
they also don't know how how dirty it is
to actually produce the green energy
they they have no idea how much like how
these rechargeable batteries and things
like that they they sit there and well
well here's whatever
someone someone posted uh there's a meme
going around it's been on twitter and
facebook and it says the cost to produce
wind energy has gone up zero dollars in
zero cents since the war in russia and
ukraine i said that's not true the cost
of petrol lubricants for these have gone
up you're lying stop lying to me just
tell me the truth i can't take it so not
only that tim but think about this and
our ports did i mention we've got seven
imports more than the other member of
college yes and by the way we have
strategic petroleum reserves about 60
percent of the nations and and why why
is that called strategic petroleum
reserves it's in our district because
it's strategic you want to keep that oil
there until you need it for a strategic
reason don't just release it so you want
to try to get out underneath owning the
fact that you've increased the price of
fuel but
um
i was gonna i will say releasing it
didn't even do anything to drive down
prices anyway right well yes we use like
what 20 million a day windmills come
through our ports and guess what they
come on the back of when they get moved
from the port and to the
18 wheelers and guess what
and guess what 18 wheelers burn oh i
know diesel i have no problem saying
that uh wind turbines are fantastic in
my opinion you said texas texas number
one win but once it's awesome it's
awesome but just stop lying to me about
everything wind is not an end-all bl
solution we need when it comes to solar
and wind we need massive battery
industrial-sized battery systems for
storage rare earth minerals where are we
going to get those you know well alaska
yeah well alaska does africa some but
right now in china a lot of the
components are from our oh i don't know
our friends in china oh yeah yeah
and rare earths actually aren't
necessarily rare we just need to start
being self-sufficient in the united
states how about making it easier to
drill easier to dig permits to mine how
about the federal government move out of
the way and let entrepreneurs and
companies do their job you know i feel
like it's because
for a lot of these democrats they need
to make sure there's a problem that they
can only be the ones to solve and we're
heavily subsidizing the green energy um
industry in general where we they were
supposed to like not have their
subsidies renewed and yet they came back
to us a second time and asked to have
them renewed and so we're paying for
that if if it is sustainable and it is
what the
what society demands and what the market
demands then we shouldn't have to be
subsidizing them let's pull up this
story from town hall from march 9th my
birthday just past week russia funneled
no thank you russia funneled cash to
anti-fossil fuel climate extremists 2018
report
they say as the cost of a gallon of gas
continues to break state and national
records many are criticizing president
biden for taking an energy independent
united states and putting the country in
the position of relying upon foreign
powers to meet american consumers demand
in addition to the pain being felt by
americans at the pump it's also become
clear that being energy dependent is a
national security liability when foes
around the world just russia china iran
at all get antsy or start an all-out war
conservatives rightly point to radical
environmentalists unhinged anti-fracking
and anti-pipeline activists and democrat
officials including biden schumer pelosi
sanders and aoc as the driving force
behind anti-fossil fuel protests they go
on to say just a few years ago through a
congressional investigation into russian
interference in u.s politics revealed
evidence that russia had a role going
back more than a decade now in the
radical campaign to get the u.s and
other western countries to shift away
from fossil fuels a goal much like one
of biden's energy secretary jennifer
granholm stated last week now the first
thing i want to say is i'm very
skeptical skeptical when it comes to the
russian collusion the the russia
influence and stuff but that's
it
it's fair to say
we know that russia china iran north
korea even smaller countries are
constantly playing these propagandistic
uh moves my question is as we're
learning about this
is it actually that severe is is russia
actually having an impact in the united
states to the point where it's going to
cause us to uh become energy dependent
or is it marginal well i'm not sure what
effect russia is having on it but it is
very telling which side of this issue
they're on
because they're not exactly interested
in they want us
they want us to buy their oil
so when it was russia russia russia with
trump right what was the incentive for
not for wanting him in there right there
was no incentive for them to
want trump to be the next president that
made no sense right it made no sense but
there was an incentive for them not to
want correct president but this this is
this there is real incentive there they
want us to buy their oil and we and we
did the moment trump gets out we go from
being an exporter to uh importer that's
right yeah we were energy independent
and we should be energy dominant we
should be the number one look you all
are way too young to remember i was
around in 1973
when the uh when the saudis taught us
about oil embargoes yep and you talked
about in some of your talks earlier
about somebody wants to re re-live or
bring back the oil export ban and we're
saying look that means jobs
i actually voted for that in 2015
in december of 2015 got beat up for a
little bit but we want to be sure we
export bans russia disinformation
was happening in the campaign earlier we
all know that it's just the democrats
had brought that out
listen what they took to the fiasco
court some of those activists in the fbi
my sons and fbi as i said earlier
most of them almost all of them great
but there was a few activists at the top
of the chain there in the fbi what they
did by lying to a federal court the fisa
court if you and i brought information
to a friend of any kind of court and
cert and signed off that it was right
they knew it wasn't right we would be
under the jailhouse so that russia
collusion is kind of stuck in people's
crawl for a long time but when we
discovered this in 2017 lamar smith and
i wrote a letter right then to uh steve
mnuchin secretary of the treasury and
said look there's some money laundering
going on here you need to check into it
and there's a lot of facts that show
shale companies in bermuda that have
been moving money over into sierra club
for example sea change there's a whole
bunch of clubs that get them i could go
on the list i've got a list here in my
notes
and they literally are funding some of
the stuff going on over there that's a
fact you can't deny it and look at this
look at this photo the town hall has
look at that smile as joe biden shakes
the hand of vladimir putin well that
proves it that proves they're colluding
this is what they did so much of with
trump absolutely i just i showed trump
next to putin's oh yeah yeah like biden
just looks like
smiling like an idiot
this looks really
really actually well hold on hold on
looks like he's like no hold on uh joe
biden looks like beavis
actually does he does come on man
did you see that one video
there was that one video of trump
shaking putin's hand and like pulling
him in yeah oh he does that yeah he does
he would he would shake their hand and
then pull everybody yeah like assert
your dominance that's not what's
happening there who was who was the one
person i think trudeau
like pushed his leg out and then didn't
let trump do it and then all the left
was like yeah go trudeau and they were
cheering or whatever yeah i'm wondering
what they're thinking about him today
what about those same truckers think
they they they still keep defending
people like that so so
i think it's fair to point out as we
previously mentioned putin has a real
reason to incentivize the united states
to get off of fossil fuels so that we
become dependent upon them it's not hard
we also have uh natural gas in europe as
well has there been any indication that
they're doing similar practices in
europe oh absolutely the actual campaign
went against fossil fr fuels in in terms
of fracking in terms of lng
uh everything that they did in europe
and and they're doing over here now my
district as you know exports lng and
they look for 20-year contracts
and so when they contract with a country
like poland and some of the others it's
a long-term contract
putin is seeing that he doesn't want
that lng is a bit esoteric so just once
again for anyone who's liquefied
liquefied natural gas yeah well yeah
that's
real quick that's north stream too uh
right there doing liquefied natural gas
from russia to germany yeah and the
interesting thing is the ceo of
nordstream 2 is a friend of who knew
putin one of his confidants yep right
and even of gas prom one of the top one
of the top officials of gas prom is a a
friend of putin's i think they have ties
back to not the 90s when they were
together in the mayor's office right
well i got it i got to i got to ask you
about um joe biden and barisma
i mean you seem to be one of the experts
on energy if not the expert and so you
take a look at what's happening with uh
you know donald trump ukraine gate
barisma hunter biting out the laptop
story yeah my my my view of this because
i've been i've been following these
stories for you know almost a decade
with the qatar turkey pipeline syria
assad and of course the u.s trying to i
should say the west wanting to offset
russia's control of natural gas through
ukraine you've got gas coming through
israel you could come up to cyprus and
yeah there's a lot of discussion about
that too so uh
what what's the religion is there
something going on was there something
going on with the u.s barisma in
attempting to shut down russia's you
know control with you know that's one
thing i'm not familiar with i started
hearing first hearing about that with
with the biden thing when literally joe
biden hunter biden
and by the way i know they're concerned
because with ukraine and a heck of a
mess it is now i mean does that mean
hunter biden's salaries getting cut
but any investigation about that was
shut down his check bounce right like
well
[Laughter]
well and look joe biden you know he did
this on a video he said you know what i
told them that if they didn't fire this
guy that was investigating that company
he said they don't get the one billion
dollars right and sob
you know what do you know six hours
later he was fired yeah it really does
feel uh uh to me like you know i think
there's nato's interest in getting a
cheaper gas into europe and then i feel
like biden was uh looking to wet his
whistle he thought hey look here's my
opportunity we're gonna it's in the us
interest to do this but i'm gonna make
some money off it germany's really
intertwined in all this too they have
this like rosa luxembourg foundation and
they are affiliated with democratic
socialists and they have an office in
new york um and they hold these training
sessions on how to like protest
pipelines and fracking and the whole
nine yards and they they also do they
team up with um sea change and the
sierra club so then there's this guy ben
beachy who works for the sierra club
who's he meeting with on the hill lately
aoc jayapal all of them and then you go
to his social media he said every single
antifa protest everyone i wonder if aoc
you know is aware
of what the ramifications of her
advocacy would mean
uh i i like to shout out greta tunberg
you know everyone's you know how dare
you um because i stole him she has that
quote where she said we don't want to
wait until 2030 or 2023 we want to end
fossil fuels now
how many people would you estimate will
die overnight if we immediately just
shut off fossil fuels 60 million oh my
gosh you know just think of the just
think of the cold winter's up north uh
and you know new york doesn't by the way
the state of new york doesn't buy lng
from america they buy it from russia wow
we they do we call it the dirty putin
yes wait wait wait so so now that we've
banned imports from russia new york is
in trouble that you would sure hope so
you betcha
well you can't trust the buying
administration they may have carved out
an exception you know what i mean but
think about it
and not only that but we generate
electricity with it in the south so
people could die from no air
conditioning in the south in the
summertime when it's 100 degrees
diabetics instantly because you insulin
is going to be refrigerated
people can't drive to work food spoils
absolutely in hospitals oh yeah and
those who are on
dialysis machines
i don't think the squad gets it and my
wife i told my wife that we ought to
call them the odd squad and she said
don't tell people that
i love it so you just did
so if you want to see that it's randy he
always does what he's not supposed to do
i'm not supposed to say they're the odds
what i'm saying yeah but i i really do
wonder if uh
i i i'm of the opinion that
ocasio-cortez absolutely knows people
will die
and she doesn't care i genuinely because
these are these are not the kind of
people that would come on a show like
this and actually have a sit-down
conversation about those things she's
not the kind of person i mean look when
she told the story on january 6
when she told the story of january 6 she
completely fabricated it and just i i
have to tell everybody every time this
comes this comes up but she said there's
a knock on her door and
then she went in the bathroom and she
heard someone say where is she yeah and
she she thought to herself
they made it in the issue was
that incident happened an hour before
anyone breached the capitol building so
the office is in our building just so
you know so
her office is in our building no no for
sure and it didn't happen at all but
what happened was when conservatives
pointed that out the media said yes but
there are tunnels so aoc being scared
was reasonable and i said no it wasn't
because her story happened a full hour
before anyone even knew the building was
going to be breached yeah which means if
there's no possible way she was in her
office thinking to herself they made it
here she made that up and she was
colluding with those who were born
absolutely the only tunnel they could
have gotten through through the capital
would be the cannon tunnel which was
immediately the first thing they shut
down so not true so the whole story is
fabricated and when you hear things like
that i just assume
she
she makes things up
so it's possible that she doesn't know
what she's talking about when it comes
to climate and she's just saying
whatever she needs to say that's why i
believe but it's also possible she's
completely aware of what it would mean
to just shut off fossil fuels and do
what she's planning on doing i mean the
whole green new deal look when when the
green new deal was first being proposed
it was it was a bit vague it was this
idea of government investing in green
energy and i in my opinion i'm like that
sounds fantastic american energy
independence the renewable doesn't say
we're not talking about getting rid of
fossil fuels we're talking about
bolstering our technology maybe even
fusion power what did we get the bill
was social justice free college free
health care and get rid of farting cows
well she's the boss tim
you remember that no one else is
proposing ideas i'm the boss right oh
right right but you know what she did
that was smart that like republicans i
don't seem to always do is that she
messaged it and messaged it and messaged
it when she was she had no power she was
a freshman in congress right right she
got it in the minds of every single
person out there through the young
people and all and then now they had to
do something with it so it has evolved
over time and that's why organizations
like rosa luxembourg foundation and
these people that are doing this
propaganda are latching onto that and
filling it filling that with terrible
substance because she doesn't have it on
her own i i just want to say i feel like
if you took the average american who
votes a democrat and just sat them down
with say you randy and aoc they'd be
voting republican after half an hour or
they'd be calling him racist enough no i
no i don't think so you don't think so
there are there are they're right there
are culti people who just want to fit in
i'm talking about your regular working
class person who says i need to feed my
kids
conversations like this we don't see
them these people don't come on the show
we've invited many people on the left
it's it's hard to get what we end up
getting is mock offers from leftist
personalities who want to just troll us
sometimes we do have more left-leaning
personalities who are willing to come on
the show and they'll argue with us but
for the most part
it's a very serious concern greta
tunberg said shut down fossil fuels
right now that would result in 60
million or so dead
what's your proposal you never get an
answer to those questions because
they're not willing to answer them on
these shows i don't think they're
genuine people which is why i say you
take a regular person you take aoc you
take randy you put them in a room and
they're going to walk out and be like i
didn't get any answers from the left
yeah i mean you're right from the
perspective of these left-wing activists
they have no reason to justify any of
their positions they're just correct as
was summarized by aoc when she said
people will criticize you for being
factually inaccurate when you're morally
correct oh yeah that was great
yeah so are you saying when you say the
lefties won't come on so chris cuomo
hasn't accepted your
invitation well i'm actually i i would
assume
first of all with chris cuomo he's he's
he's probably too big you know he
doesn't care he's getting paid millions
of dollars now he's doing a suit and
we're not fans of his he probably
wouldn't want to come on just because
you know we've been you know
very very like opposed to him
but um well and you're telling things
like it is right people ought to be did
i mention people ought to be sharing
this program
oh you know i'll give you i'll give you
a really good example um genkuger of the
young turks or anna casparian for
instance i understand they do their own
show it's a fair point to say they have
no time to come out here to the east
coast and come on our show when they do
their own show
however they have done they go out of
their way often to misrepresent our
views and lie about us just today the
daily beast wrote a fake story about uh
tulsi gabbard as well as me it was uh
jared holt who used to work for right
wing right wing watch he just wrote a
fabricated narrative falsely accusing us
of pushing a cue conspiracy about bio
labs in ukraine when all we did here on
the show was say wow victoria nuland
testified before the senate that she was
concerned about these bio labs and then
they try and make it seem like we're
pushing weird conspiracies about
vladimir putin stopping weapons or
something which we never did and so when
you so we've invited jared holt on the
show several times he won't do it he
won't come on the show and i think it's
because he knows
he will be absolutely eviscerated in
terms of the facts how about it yeah
they're able to stand in their ivory
tower shouting down lies to the chances
they have no reason to come here and be
proven wrong and you know victoria
newland was a holdover from obama right
oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so she testified there's a ukraine
has biolabs and there's a fear that if
russia gets a hold of them you know
there could be problems
and that's what we said in fact what we
did say as well was we said uh the maps
showing
russian attacks and biolabs don't even
sync up
and yet the daily beast publishes a
story accusing tulsi gabbard me tucker
carlson of pushing lies
in line with the with with the kremlin
for simply citing victoria newland
these people won't come on and be proven
wrong which is why i say if you sat down
with them and and and here's the
fascinating thing too like you're
sitting here saying you know texas is
the is the win state is what number one
you said right yes sir
that's great news to many of these
people on the left texas is doing a
fantastic job in terms of renewable but
you've got some honest points to make
you need year-round energy to be
available and wind can't can't be all of
that that's right
but they don't want to hear it and
they're and and we know that some of the
elements in in the wind energy system uh
especially if you're talking about
batteries and solar panels and stuff
they hate nuclear the left hates nuclear
because they don't want to know what to
do with the waste and they pretty much
they killed yucca mountain even though
that was a great design
and so wind energy has waste at some
point in time there's going to be
something that's got to be done
something with batteries are the same
way if you've ever had a car with a
battery it needed to be replaced guess
what it's going to be done something
done with it and it's really difficult
to to deal with these large massive
electric car batteries yeah and it's and
it's also where do they think the
electricity comes from for these
electric cars
the fascinating thing is
you know
i really wish these people would take
energy economics 101 the basic beginning
so they can undertake understand things
like energy return on energy invested
they can understand the root of all
energy and the us and and human economy
i watch this really great documentary
and it starts off in you know tribal
caveman era and it said the first form
of energy utilized by man was man's own
energy using his own arms to to
run to hunt and then we started using
tools and leverage
then we started at some point lumber
burning wood and burning wood allowed us
to do things then we had coal then you
know we apply coal to say steam for from
from motion develop the wheel in order
to move things right
it was talking about
i'm sorry i skipped over animals so
humans use their own hands then they
started using basic tools for leverage
but then they used animal energy cows
could eat oxen could eat grass and then
pull something they couldn't pull
eventually they figured out to burn you
know carbon then eventually coal then
eventually we discovered petroleum which
was massively energy dense nuclear
energy and so we're constantly trying to
find ways to maximize energy output with
minimal energy input and that's energy
return on energy invested which
they don't understand any of these
concepts and especially the investment
part of it you know when you've got a
federal government that's so anti-fossil
fuel making it's so hard for people to
invest money and i don't care whether
it's a windmill farm whether it's a
nuclear facility whether it's a gas fire
power plant
when you've got to jump through all the
hoops and all the regulations and it
takes two or three years to plan
something uh they're making it hard to
build energy and you've got china out
there depends on whose numbers you're
using
making a coal plant a week a month
whatever it is is i don't know if you
you know the answer but is nuclear has
the uh highest energy return on energy
invested is it nuclear might be
petroleum it's gonna depend on the
market value at any given point right
right right yeah but i will tell you
that for nuclear to go and put in a
nuclear system and a facility and it's
billions of dollars yeah now so the
payback is going to stretch way out and
when you're an investor and you're
looking at those things and the federal
government's making it extremely hard
for you on the front end to even get a
permit let's just say in two years you
go i don't want to necessarily wait that
long i should probably uh
give an understanding of was it
e-r-o-e-i or whatever uh for people who
don't understand it's basically
fracking for a long time was what would
produce less energy than we would put
into it it was not worth producing it
the investment wouldn't come back out of
it and then once gas prices started to
become more higher and higher all of a
sudden we could put in the energy to get
energy back so what this means is
if you spend let's let's do it by hours
it's a really easy way to understand it
if it takes you 100 hours to get a wind
turbine up but that wind turbine can
only produce 101 hours of energy it's a
very very weak return on building this
massive structure so you're using
petroleum energy to get back even one i
think
a lot of these renewables actually have
a negative return so we're having solar
installed at uh at our new facility and
we're looking at i think it's you know
30 or 40 years before we generate enough
energy to cover the energy required to
make the panels and the batteries
so we use oil
to run the machines that make the solar
and the batteries and that system cannot
generate more energy than the oil that
was put into it it's it's convenient for
us that if the power goes out we will
have backup power it's convenient for us
that we can generate our own power on a
sunny day but it takes oil energy to
give us that convenience hopefully in
the future we're at a point where we can
use wind energy to charge electric
vehicles and factories to build more
wind energy but that's the big change
one of the big challenges we face well
don't think about all the stuff that was
built in that scenario you just laid out
if you're building up silting they're
bringing huge solar panels it's going to
be carried by a diesel truck that uses
diesel maybe we'll do cyber truck
maybe we'll have the uh elon musk
delivered by cyber truck powered by
solar panels
but uh certainly we're decades away from
anything like that i'm gonna say that's
going to be before i'll be long gone by
then yeah right we're going to miss you
i do i do think
that the challenge is
that uh
just oil is so massively energy dense
which provides a great opportunity the
the discovery and implementation of oil
you can see it in human population
expansion it was just massive well
here's the other thing too tim we have
been good and look fossil fuel in and of
itself is not the enemy
we can produce energy cleanly from
fossil fuel
in fact i was on the environmental red
committee in the state of texas i
mentioned earlier and we oversaw a lot
of the emissions in texas you know we
have our own facility uh tcerq tax
commission or environmental quality in
texas it's the second largest
environmental regulatory agency in the
country second only to the epa
and we do a good job of monitoring our
things in texas we were reducing
emissions when you've got when we kill
our if the left gets their way and they
kill fossil fuel
i'm sure that when we kill our fossil
fuel industry then china's going to
follow suit india is going to follow
suit and mexico is going to follow suit
russia is going to follow suit no
we can produce energy cleanly and china
doesn't produce energy as clean with you
as we do russia doesn't do it india
doesn't do it mexico doesn't do it
they're major polluters and so why are
we seeking to kill our energy industry
over here when it be less than i forget
what the figure is less than 1 100th of
a percent of all the emissions in the in
the world
no we need to be doing it as cleanly as
we can and it's national security it's
domestic security it's economic security
and it's family security quite frankly
because as you pointed out they've got
to be able to drive cars go to the
grocery store that's right well let's go
to super chats if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and uh get your super chats in now so
we'll be reading as many as we can at
around 11 or so p.m with a members only
segment of the podcast going up for
everybody at timcast.com and uh let's
read some super chats the first super
chat can't read your name unfortunately
to say why does ian look like sheamus
uh yeah cut his hair i don't know what
you're talking about cut his air in his
agent half yeah that's right that's
right there you go on st patrick's day
he didn't wear green and he just morphed
into it well no ian wasn't wearing green
and james just you know just just
he had to hit him right that's that's
what you don't say that's kind of how it
works and then i'm not wearing green
either but i don't have to he started
crying and he ran and locked his locked
himself in his room embarrassing
no ian's sick he in sick but he'll be
all right
all right let's see
awesome archivist says tim i love your
content but i have one criticism kids
born
1996-2002 are completely different from
those born in 2003 to 2013 because of
the technological jump when the first
iphone came out that i totally
understand absolutely
all right eric miller says since sheamus
is taking ian's place what what are his
thoughts on graphene and the federal
reserve that's a really good question i
need so i have a graphene expert he's
sick right now but i will consult with
him before the next show and then i'll
let you guys know
all right see hennessy says randy my
dude what's your best advice for someone
tempted running for congress in their
home district i ask because the reps for
my district don't even live here and i'd
hate to vote for them oh wow
well you better be from your district
you better be the real deal i love a
business background i owned an air
conditioned company for 35 years my
wife's a school teacher of 27 years
she's retired you ought to be well
grounded in your district
be the real deal
now let talk to people tell them what
your plan is have a plan work that plan
and tell them what you'll do tell them
what you will do and then do it but it's
also important to start out local so um
randy started out like everybody should
or you know on the local level
commissioner first then state you gotta
you have to earn it you have to earn it
you have to start local and do school
board do county commissioner do state
rep and then and then build your way up
you can't sometimes people just think oh
i'll just run for congress but you have
to establish yourself first and get
people to know you if you want more
advice randywebber.org
all right murph tries says tim in the
multiverse would cuomo be working for
project veritas
there exists a universe where cuomo has
exposed cnn just imagine this there's a
universe where cuomo never worked for
cnn and he like got into a fight with
his family and he was like i don't want
to be a part of this establishment
machine and he meets james o'keefe and
they become best friends and then cuomo
goes undercover and exposes the whole
thing i really want to know what like
the dating thing is like there because
they they put these girls on dates with
these guys like how many dates you have
to go on
to get like that information out of them
and what are the ethics behind it and
like i think that we somebody needs to
come on and explain that process i have
a feeling
what happens with project veritas
because they use tinder and stuff is
that
they're mostly just swiping trying to
like imagine this how do you even find
the guy you have to just
keep swiping until you find someone says
i work at cnn and then hope they respond
to you yeah but i guess if you swipe
you'll get it but i'd imagine men kind
of swipe to everybody isn't that right
so and if they work at cnn they don't
have that many other options
but but i'd imagine the first date the
first date with any one of these people
these guys are hamming it up and just
saying everything trying to seem like
they're more important and cool by by
exposing the stuff look what i know
exactly
so when you get and it's probably very
easy for veritas's journalists to to say
things like oh yeah you know trump's bad
but i mean come on cnn kind of pushes it
right and then they're gonna be like oh
right yeah here's what we've done
because now they think they have a way
to impress this young woman it's
brilliant i don't know if i could fake
being a democrat for like more like for
life
i don't think i i don't think it could
happen that would suck
all right all right we got all these
jokes about sheamus and ian and
everything
you guys should really be more sensitive
says
if the red wave comes are the mechanisms
for republicans to overrule biden's
energy policy or kamala if biden is
impeached first
uh
let me try and rephrase that
uh when the red wave comes in november
will you guys be able to actually
commandeer and start fixing this energy
policy yes we have a plan we don't want
to have what happened after obama was
there we want to repeal obamacare and
you know the famous thing about the
senator i don't want to from arizona i
don't want to disrespect him but he
voted down put the thumbs down
yeah you know i don't do that so we have
to have a plan do it we're going to do
now don't forget and biden even said it
was it yesterday or was the day part of
the democratic conference caucus he said
he said if that happens
all i will have is a veto pin in the
white house
so we will do everything we can to stop
the bad bills from the
they're just passing everything right
now left and right and of course he's
more than happy to sign him so we will
be able to shut down the progressive
left the liberals the socialistic uh
attempt to take over our country and the
president will be there simply to stop
us from you know we can only yeah we're
going to hold on to 20 until trump wins
here's something you guys should look
out for though get with gas prices being
so high democrats are looking for ways
to bring these costs down and some of it
they want to do like a highway tax um
like a gas tax they want to eliminate
the gas tax they want they're looking to
do cash payments right and so if they
put these policies out and the american
public who doesn't pay attention thinks
it's a good thing and they watch
republicans vote it down then when it
comes time for midterms that gets a
little dicey it'll be funny when joe
biden is like we're going to give every
american a thousand dollars a month to
pay for gas yep and then it's just one
more step towards socialized they are
talking about that they did that in the
pandemic and you know they couldn't get
a bill brought to the floor last week
because they couldn't agree that they
wanted more money for pandemic 80 was it
80 billion or something like that and
they didn't even have the votes to bring
them to the floor well we have a good
question right here it's an interesting
one bear essentials says has biden done
anything good as president
no has biden done anything good as
president
he uh increased the timeline on
releasing the vaccine by like a month he
spat up the timeline yeah he still had
more covet deaths in cases that whole
year so he kind of botched the whole
thing so i don't know if he can get
credit for that because it didn't work
out for him yeah
i'm not going to comment on the vaccine
i don't want to tank your show
yes he has done something good as
president he's kept kamal harris from
becoming president
no but he chose her for the vp
he put her closer to the presidency than
anyone could have
i don't know i'll we'll leave it there
all right let's read this one from
austin he says tim if due process is all
that is needed to justify your rights
being taken away then you should be fine
with gun control laws as the legislative
process is due process all be it albeit
wrong and unconstitutional no that's not
due process that is that is incorrect
the constitution says supreme law of the
land and it says the right keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed it is not
due process would be amending the
constitution not just arbitrarily
passing laws that violate the
constitution in which case due process
is if you commit crimes
now we as a society can say you have
violated some kind of you know committed
a crime that being said
where is the line right so we talk about
free speech and hate speech if we say
okay well look we all agree illegal
speech is not free speech right like
threatening people
couldn't the government just pass a law
saying okay well this is considered a
threat as well and then they can just
keep encroaching on free speech well
they do threat assessments all the time
you know we get a lot of death threats
from across the country well there was a
guy that issued one to us
and it's one thing to get them from new
york california wherever but there was a
guy that issued one that lived 30 miles
south of me wow fbi went out and picked
him up oh boy because it's credible
death yeah right you know that's the old
famous supreme court case you're right
to scream shout fire is a curtailed in
the theater
we've uh we've had i think we've been
swatted more than any other show this
year yeah it's exciting six times
explained spotting for all right do you
know because i don't know
this is when someone calls the local
police
and then says something wild and
outrageous to trigger a swot response to
your address
so while we were doing the show
it was the day it was january 6 was the
day after we had marjorie taylor green
she came around the fifth someone called
in and claimed they had killed someone
and so cops show up you know multiple
jurisdictions were called and they show
up surround the house they have their
you know they're
you know pulling up the lights on
they're like put your hands in the air
and then the people outside have to put
their hands up and then it's happened
six times
it's now involving two different states
and then we had the bomb squad here just
the other day so we're we're getting
these you know you're on the right track
people you need to share this program
yeah well there you go apparently
you don't have anything if you don't
have any enemies you're doing something
wrong well i i talked about this in a
segment on my morning show as to why
it's happening and i think it's because
we're a fairly moderate you know like
we're kind of middle the road a lot of
issues we're not over you know overtly
conservative ian who was normally here
is kind of a weird uh
i don't know i don't know describes
politics wild card but sometimes you
know he's he's it favors establishment
never sometime he doesn't so it's not
all he likes graphene and hates the
federal reserve yeah
but but but sometimes he'll agree with
you know like he was he was kind of uh
arguing in favor of covid restrictions
to a certain degree like
he's pro-death penalty so so he's a wild
card but i was thinking maybe it's
because they can't ban us and they and
there's no way to you know they can go
after crowder with strikes and get him
off the air but for us we have you know
you randy on the show we have marjorie
taylor green on the show with steve
bannon we had alex jones we have these
people that many of these activists and
and figures don't like what can you
really do to try and hinder us if we're
not breaking the rules and getting
banned they need to go forward and
target us with very serious threats you
know they they try lying and coming
after our advertisers and things like
that but we're mostly a member supported
network so it's the people who watch who
go to timcast.com and be members that
keep us floating so we've really taken
away a lot of their ability to censor us
the one thing it seems they have left is
death threats and swatting and sure you
know bomb scares and things like that
well the crazies are out there that's
true yup
all right
matthew gill says
please ask rep weber if he will be
voting for the sunshine protection act
when it goes to the house if so my
circadian rhythms thank him are we
talking about the daylight savings phil
i think that's what it is right i think
we're i think we're debating this still
right like what do you think we've been
debating me and my wife have been
debating
so stay stay tuned
i i just think it's so silly because
it's you just wake up early yeah you
know i'm so confused by that just wake
up an hour i wake up at 7 am every day
i'm thoroughly convinced that convinced
that maybe it's just me maybe the
science isn't in yet but i think the sun
rises at the same time every morning
it's true you know and i think it sits
the same time every evening so that's
that's the weirdest thing to me how it's
like we all need to agree a society
we're changing our clocks the same time
and i'm like dude i can just wake up
early that's right
that's that's your answer right there
you know what i'm saying yeah to be fair
when i worked in the hospital a lot of
the nurses would complain that they
would get up and go to work in the dark
and then they'd come home in the dark
and it was really frustrating well
actually i think the bigger issue is
just
daylight savings time seems irrelevant
and we should get rid of it yeah and if
that's what the bill does then we're
getting rid of it and i say good you
know they tried it before though getting
rid of it yeah in the 70s and and kids
were still like walking to school every
day and things like that and there were
an increase of children getting hurt run
over by cars and hit and well but i
think so they switch it back well i
think what they're saying now though is
not to get rid of it it's that we're
gonna make it always
you know we're gonna we're gonna make it
so it's daylight more by moving the
clocks back or whatever so we all wake
up early or something that's what they
were saying but still it's only what
they're trying to do is the same thing
what they want now is it to be late like
um light out later in the afternoon um
and they're saying now that kids are not
walking to school like they used to that
won't be an impediment this is the
stupidest thing ever have the kids come
to school an hour early and leave an
hour earlier either you go out in the
dark or you come in in the dark yeah and
so it's fairly simple um have your kids
come to school earlier that makes no
sense tonight is just the weirdest thing
get rid of all of it whatever people
don't understand that because they're in
the dark yeah exactly that's interesting
all right common sense phishing says
your punishment should end with your
sentence i was 19 innocent got screwed
and got a strike and felony i'm 40 hvac
contractor father and husband no trouble
in over 20 years i want my two-way
rights back i agree 100 yes sir and we
agree absolutely
so that's something uh you interested in
repealing the nfa
the nfa yeah the national firearms act
um you know what i'm not that familiar
with it i think that everybody have the
right to carry a gun this is like yes
wait no no we filled out we had to fill
out a gun owners of america survey and
it was like do you repeal this he
answered yes on every single one when he
had the legislation in front of him so
the the national firearms act is what
basically uh stops people or makes it
very difficult to own selected
yeah yeah i forget what they call it yes
yeah you betcha all right there we go no
no no i'm sorry she's right i have phil
daddy
he has i was in the last thing there and
i'm like how do you feel about this one
how do you feel about this one and he
has voted
i tell people i hate acronyms right i'm
on a one-man uh thing to stamp out
acronyms yeah you were saying asap
yeah so um
i got i got a bunch of these you know
lefty activists mad at me because i said
the second amendment protects your right
to keep and bear nuclear arms and
biological arms
i do i think so i'm not saying i'm not
saying people should have them i'm
saying that if it is plain that the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed it does not go on to explain
what that meant in fact
back in the day privateers and corsairs
had they had her own frigates frigates
they had you know grapes shot they had
cannons absolutely they did they had the
same weapons as their government exactly
and the governments issued letters of
mark and reprisal so they could go and
use them correct absolutely so you know
the funny thing is too
halliburton boeing lockheed martin these
are private companies they have these
weapons yes they do so why can't any you
know why is it only these special
privileged companies no so they got mad
at me and they were like tim poole says
that the second amendment grants people
the right and i'm like they cut they cut
it because i was i set a whole paragraph
actually and they had to end the video
as fast as possible because i went on to
say something to the effect of like i'm
not saying anyone should have these
things i'm saying we should amend the
constitution and most people would
probably agree people should not have
nuclear weapons and biological weapons
right that's right but they cut that
part out because you know they want to
lie oh yeah absolutely imagine that yep
yep but i think um you know one thing
that the left really doesn't understand
uh especially with fully automatic
weapons is that
when it when it comes to these mass
shooting incidents and tragedies as much
as it might sound shocking you would if
someone is going first of all we don't
want any of these things ever to happen
right no but if someone has full auto a
full auto rifle it ends the circum the
situation much more quickly
because they'll spray and pray they'll
miss they'll unload all their rounds and
then be left with no more ammo
so you're actually it's actually a
you know banning full auto doesn't
actually make anything safer it's
probably the best way to put it
plus it also uh the national firearms
act restricts uh suppressors which also
make firing a weapon substantially safer
for everybody it's the weirdest thing
yeah it takes a long time to get a
suppressor now i've heard about from
some of my constituents yeah it takes
like a year about a year i'm told but
what does a suppressor do you know to
people who watch this as well saying the
left they watch the hollywood movies
where it's
they've never actually gone out and
fired one and it's not making that sound
and you're still wearing your ear
protection no kidding yeah they need to
educate themselves and if they haven't
been able to do that they ought to at
least take a shot at it
this guy's got all the puns and dad
jokes in i love it i told you it was
going to be a night of that but it's all
good fun
all right let's uh let's see what we
have
wesley luck says for randy i was born
and raised in
brazoria county ron paul delivered uh
delivered some of my friends wow how do
you feel about him and his history in
washington how do you relate to his
limited government ideals
well i said i had his endorsement uh and
i told i don't know how long you've been
watching but you need to watch this
program frequently that's it and you
need to share it with your friends
but but uh i had his endorsement um and
uh his district obviously it's a little
changed with redistricting but limited
government and tell people i'm a
christian conservative republican and
ron paul i think identified more as a
libertarian but he was on the right
track audit the fed make them
accountable amen there's a there's a lot
of things that he that he was on the
right track with a lot of people took
advantage to some of his stances
one of them was that he thought iran
ought to be able to get a nuclear weapon
which i didn't agree with that because
they're nuts over there they're
religious nut jobs that's the
libertarian in them though you know
absolutely i get that but anyway uh for
the most part we're pretty much lockstep
um
uh he's still in my district over in
lake jackson we see him riding a bicycle
every now and then
absolutely a great guy and we still have
some of his staff left over we do have
some of these things do we still have
his picture on the gym door we do yeah
oh yeah so we have that license two
christmases ago wow when our friend luke
kowski was here who's uh i think he's
also friends with with uh with ron paul
right he uh uh we put the christmas tree
and one day i came out and there's a
picture of ron paul on top and he said i
couldn't decide between a star or an
angel so i chose both
nice
i'm good friends with rand and i'm good
and actually his daughter is a doctor in
our area lives in the same town that i
do big fans of rand paul as well yeah so
so after the tree came down we put it up
again last christmas
and then whenever whenever the trick
comes down the picture which is just
printed off of a printer it's just stuck
to the window because well no one's
gonna throw it away you know so now we
have we have rand paul i'm sorry ron
paul at the door to our little workout
area our little gym yeah
all right raymond g stanley jr says
mcshamus sir remember world war ii
wasn't that cool yeah man we should try
to do that again
you guys please please please check out
our newest cartoon from freedom tunes
just go over there youtube.com slash
freedom tunes you'll get the reference
yeah
[Laughter]
all right here we go jonathan m thomas
says let me guess i bet this congressman
is okay with ukrainian refugees coming
here but was probably against syrian and
afghan refugees coming here and doesn't
want mexicans mexicans bad ukrainians
good
didn't i discuss that earlier i'm not
against illegal immigration
against mexicans or hispanics we wanted
to do it the right way there so you are
against illegal immigration well i'm
against illegal immigration absolutely
now
we went through this with afghanis those
who helped our country those who stood
by our side whether they were
interpreters or whatever they were
we owe them a debt of privilege you know
uh sacrificed and thankful for them and
they need to be able to come over here
but they need to be vetted not just
everybody want we want to get them on a
plane because they said they helped they
need to be vetted had biden not
withdrawn from afghanistan in such a
haphazard fashion then we could have
done that a lot better a lot better
way
uh ukrainians same thing if they're
going to come over here they need to be
vetted
but why would the ukrainians come over
here yeah i wouldn't think they i think
they would want to stay close to
countries where they're from and i said
that by the way about afghanistan
syrians afghanistan's iraqis whoever go
to the countries around you now you
alluded to this earlier tim we're a
country with a lot of wealth people want
to come participate in that i get that
you know this is what what bugs me a lot
because um i mentioned that i know
people in ukraine i have a friend and uh
i'd love for them to be able to visit
here but it's it's just very very
difficult and it's kind of it's kind of
insulting and frustrating when it's like
i would like to invite my friend to come
visit you know my home i've been to her
home
but people who are at the southern
border can just break in and sneak in
yeah and you know there's even you know
she's even had the joke she was like
maybe i just go to mexico because then
well they don't care and come up to the
southern border get separated from your
kids and get 450 thousand dollars
i want to say something though in your
defense about that we did try to help
some afghani refugees and where did we
help relocate them to albania not here
yeah so we were working with these other
people getting names on list of people
that helped and and we helped them get
to albania i interviewed uh two syrian
brothers
who were separated by the war in syria
one was in turkey one was in romania
and i was talking to so what happened
was well before the war broke out one
brother got a visa to go to romania to
live and work the younger brother didn't
you know didn't and then when war broke
out and they tried conscripting
everybody he was like i need to get out
of here because this country's falling
apart yeah but the only place you could
go was turkey
he can't enter the you know the eu or
whatever so
i think roman is eu right but uh i was
talking to the the brother in romania
and he said the the strangest thing to
me was that so many of the people from
syria tried coming to germany to france
and to europe instead of lebanon yeah
where they spoke the same language and i
heard a story about uh this may have
been when i was in france actually not
from one of the refugee brothers that
somebody who was from syria who spoke
arabic had the opportunity to go and
work as a lawyer in lebanon but decided
to go and just be in a refugee shelter
in france instead and they didn't
understand why you would do that
and so this is one of one of the issues
we face
ukrainians deserve help 100
but why would we bring ukrainians all
the way out to the united states there's
so many countries in europe that can
help i mean poland is doing fantastic
work to help them absolutely
and that's and that's the way it should
be all those countries around should be
rallying and by the way they should be
rallying with military support too for
ukraine
they have the most to lose they're right
next door yup and they're saying putin's
becoming unhinged if you're listening to
the reports it sounds like it yeah it
does i i feel like he
look the west has become more and more
influential and grown and russia has
been dwindling and even you've got these
young russians who are on instagram
talking about how much
they hate the war and their lives are
being destroyed by it and putin is
seeing that he's losing the culture war
yeah in russia and i don't know if you
know this or not but texas economy is so
large that we have a larger economy than
russia wow
let's read this one this is from caleb
he says i'm an electrician and we've
been contracted to install secondary
safety switches on diesel pumps at cw
matthews asphalt plants around ga
because they have had so much diesel
fuel stolen in the last month also he
says no ian we peon no man well there
you go
yeah it's crazy like you know that's uh
what's happening with uh stealing gas
tj says thank you randy i moved to
austin texas a year uh plus a go to be
free as uh and i am thank you for your
help with that
is there some did i miss another one
from tj i don't know
maybe i can't see it though because he
said also so sometimes super chats are
segmented yeah they get in but is it
thank you there you go yeah welcome
all right patrick reed says mr webber
why is there not more interest in
thorium power it seems like a technology
that could be useful for energy
production in the us
there actually is some discussion about
fusion and thorium being on the science
based and technology committee but not
so much right now as advanced nuclear
reactors russia is outstripping us on
nuclear reactors and they're not our
friend there's a news flash that's come
about in the last what two or three
weeks or so
but there is talk about that there is
talk about it but right now we're
focused on the next round of what they
call smr small modular reactors
um and the different a different style
of reactors that don't just melt down
when something's wrong they have salt
molten salt in them and there's all
kinds of technical stuff i could tell
you
thorium has been discussed briefly but
not as much as nuclear reactors right on
nathan coxy says i'm tim poole and i
like do da cha-cha
that's what he wrote it's a reference to
uh bruce almighty for those are not
familiar but i definitely had to read
that one
good movie by the way i met the uh the
guy who uh who made it actually one time
in l.a that's great
rude uh rude says a question for your
guest how has geothermal energy come
along and perform assuming we have these
systems
well
owned my own air conditioned company for
35 years geothermal has been around a
long time we have it we got it y'all got
it here it depends on what part of the
country you're in and what the
electricity cost is and how much the
equipment cost is installation costs and
are there quite frankly any governor
government subsidies that all plays in
where i am in the market in the texas
gulf coast you just don't hardly see any
of it because electricity is pretty
reasonable well so uh i'm assuming he's
mentioning just like general geothermal
energy generation but we don't have
enough you need volcanic activity for
that right well if you want the heat you
do and you've got to be able to get heat
to produce for your heat you've got to
be able to get cold during the winter
time through water through your pipes
for the air conditioning time now i get
it up here or i guess you all don't have
a real long air conditioning season here
uh well it gets hot yeah it does get hot
a couple months couple months i mean the
same as dc so yeah well it's a little
bit better than dc to be honest dc gets
swampy right you get june to june yeah
yeah
well to me i like you know i like this
the the thermostat at 68 degrees and it
works out because we have a geothermal
system and it's cheap it is so cheap
that's why i say cost electricity in
texas sheep too now people say well
randy you really don't have a winner on
the gulf coast of texas i said yes we do
it's probably the nicest week of the
year
must be nice all right everybody if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
as we've mentioned a million times now
if you would like to help out and go to
timcast.com we're going to be filming
that members only segment right about
now you can follow the show at tim cast
irl basically everywhere except tick
tock where we're banned you can follow
me at tim cast basically everywhere
uh do you have anything to shout out
randy well i just want to say
randyweber.org for ours but listen go to
timcast.com because you you guys are
doing the lord's work thank you and so
we appreciate that uh we appreciate
being on appreciate your audience
listening they they sound like they get
it
oh you betcha we do too so thank you all
for the opportunity all right appreciate
it man lisa do you want to shout
anything out oh you know me i'm just
just chilling
all right you guys have social media
accounts or anything you want to mention
yeah he's tx randy14 um on twitter and
on instagram weber.house.gov yeah and um
uh lisa beth on instagram and lisa
elizabeth on twitter of course then my
standby campaign is though
randywebber.org
feel free to donate
[Laughter]
my name is seamus coughlin if there's
anything i'm here to promote tonight
it's freedom tunes go check it out watch
freedom tunes we released a new cartoon
today on the industrial military complex
i think you guys will enjoy it that is a
great video i highly recommend it
follow me on twitterminds.com at
sourpatchlids we will see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
you